jeff you always intended to be a film
director but your life took a different
turn
sort of um i mean earliest memories i
was
coloring on the walls with crayons and
getting in trouble
and you know writing little stories and
stuff like that and then
i was like 12 i took a summer uh one
week animation program
and just fell in love with the moving
images seeing my drawings come to life
and
became obsessive about that and met a
lifelong friend there uh
cinematographer jaren blaschke and he
and i in high school decided hey let's
try live action
and then realizing people move on their
own you have to draw them a thousand
times to get them to walk across a room
uh just fell in love with that
and so really since you know at least my
teens the moving image
and filmmaking and storytelling through
that medium really helped
um was in some little uh festivals uh
the
portland uh uh i was at the portland
young people's film
festival had a couple of early awards
there and stuff like that so and just
getting the audience feedback was so
addictive too
um and so yeah it was kind of a you know
at least a childhood goal for sure
and art school was
kind of a compromise i did i did a year
of it uh before dropping out but i
always loved you know i had a background
in drawing painting all that sort of
stuff
and just love all mediums really and uh
but um but yeah i kind of just felt like
filmmaking and art in general was in
brain surgery so
after a year of film school moved to new
york and
started paying and just kind of finding
my way from there
and when did you come to los angeles uh
five years ago now um it was after frey
came out
uh i had a handful of people telling me
i'd be an idiot not to live in la
if i wanted to keep pursuing that course
and taking advantage of those
opportunities
and i would try to fly back and forth a
handful of times and you know you'd set
up meetings and stuff like that and then
you arrive in l.a you've got a few days
and they're like oh can we push the
meeting back to next week
it's like uh no and so
um after a while i was just like yeah i
kind of need to be out here and also
there had been an exodus from new york
of a lot of my colleagues and friends
have been coming out here
so when i came to l.a i actually had a
better creative circle of
people to uh to join so just seemed like
a natural progression to come out here
better way of life more space
i mean this room alone is bigger than
any of my apartments in new york
uh so it's just it's a better it's a
better for me it's been a better
creative
and professional choice for sure
your directing reel is gorgeous and you
have so many artistic shots
even of the client work that you've done
you could really see the the detail and
the angle and how you you you know the
composition was that your plan all along
to sort of pay the bills doing client
work
and make indie films on the side not a
bad plan by the way
yeah um i've been really fortunate in
that regard
uh way back you know i was trying to
make it work i was waiting tables and
busing tables and doing whatever odd
jobs i could back in new york and
just really trying to find ways to get
my freelance career
up and running i mean i did everything
from this dates myself a bit i did a
public access tv
show for a while um i was just
constantly trying to find ways to do
things and then i fell into doing some
music videos early on which was great
um but uh even then
wasn't a you know enough to support
myself and a few evictions and
apartment changes later i was like i got
to figure this out and
fell into kind of the world of doing
fashion videos first was internals and
it started being in store videos
and then after a number of years of
doing that i was doing commercials for a
couple notable fashion brands
and that was just a great experience
because you're working with some of the
top
fashion photographers in the industry
and kind of learning
a lot from them about lighting
composition
just framing and what that does to the
perception of a person
working with great stylists and hair and
makeup teams and
creative directors i had so much to add
to
the aesthetic aspect of filmmaking um
which just i think heightened
the storytelling sensibilities as well
and then also
as a way to pay the bills it's great um
you know even uh even the small jobs are
uh there's always something that you're
learning from it it's uh
you know getting to see different
locations and what one of the locations
that
uh my new film uh blood from stone's
based around i discovered
while on his shoe we were doing a shoot
in nevada and we were staying in
laughlin and i was just walking on the
riverwalk in laughlin i'm like
this is an amazing you know you got the
casinos on one side and this raging
river on the other side and
it was just such a surreal place i'm
like i gotta shoot something here one
day
so oh sorry i'm sorry
was that part of uh where the main
character the protagonist where she was
jogging
yeah yeah that was that exact river walk
and about the same stretch i was having
that thought process while i was walking
it um yeah it was uh
there was we were staying in one of
those casinos and i i actually
just went for a walk one night and
walked all the way along the river and
across the other side
and uh yeah it was such a fascinating
place
uh and even in the casinos and the
casinos in laughlin are a different
breed than the ones i was familiar with
in vegas the big blitzy glamorous ones
they're a little more quaint a little
more run down
clientele is a different type of
clientele
and it was just it was there's so many
stories just happening there at
any given time that i just kind of had a
fascination and a bit of an obsession
and just always had that place in mind
and then this story just worked so well
with
yeah i think reno is like that as well
parts of it i don't know if you've been
but there is a sort of a nice uh i don't
know if it's the right word but
desperation
that's added into the storytelling yeah
i think works so well with that
with that uh you know the gambling and
the money it does and that's i mean i'm
a big fan of uh
location symbolism in my films i mean
i've
got the two features to speak for that
fray was obviously you know shooting the
the epic forests of uh of the pacific
northwest
and including the logging industry into
it as sort of a
metaphor for what happens to our men and
women who we send off into combat
and with this one it was similar it's a
movie about vampires and what better
place than casinos
for uh the symbolism of just these
machines that suck the
the life savings out of people
and you know so it was it was kind of a
natural fit as well it's like where else
would
you know those that have to only exist
at night be able to have a normal
existence in a casino town that never
sleeps so
um so yeah it was a very uh to me it was
i like exploring that within the film
the making the locations and the
environments a part of the story the
symbolism the
and themes throughout it because it just
you know it gives
what i did fray actually it was i almost
thought i was just being pretentious by
doing that
um i was like oh nobody's going to pay
attention to this i was really
pleasantly surprised how many people in
audiences would talk about that
afterwards about
about the symbolism of the the force
seeing the the logging and the
the wood splintered by the machines and
him cleaning up the debris
of that juxtaposed with him dealing with
his own physical wounds from war
and then the peace you would find out in
the forest with these big tall standing
trees
and the quiet there and just that back
and forth
it was amazing to see how that spoke to
audiences and how
how much they pulled from it and so i
kind of
was inspired to just keep going with
that in this film and
really weave so much of the environment
into
the actual storytelling itself not just
cool places to shoot but what do they
say some of the places we shot at were
very
very historic places uh pioneer saloon
has been there since
i think 1912 or 1913 it's an old
frontier saloon that it still has a
bullet hole in the tin wall
from a gun you know a gun fight back in
the old days and
um we had atomic liquors which is uh the
oldest freestanding bar in las vegas
where
people would go watch the atomic bomb
blasts back in the day while having some
cocktails
and el cortez casino which is the oldest
independently owned casino in vegas and
still keeps so much of its original
character
and all those things to kind of play
with the idea of the symbolizing the old
world and the old eras
contrasting with our new eras that's
trying to you know arise
or from from these old eras and
so bringing a lot of symbolism in
through those location choices i think
i think helps uh really bring the the
film together in a much more uh
realistic and fleshed out way
hoping to go back to your film that was
about
military personnel returning to civilian
life and so that was based on
a family member or lucy based yeah yeah
loosely based
my cousin ben he was a marine in iraq
and did
multiple tours and you know he and i
growing up
uh you know we're close cousins we lived
in different states the time i was in
montana he was
in oregon and washington but we'd always
meet up at grandparents place and
play military and i'd be the commander
he'd be my little soldier and then
you know flash forward 15 years later
and he's in the marines and i'm
an artist but
uh you know he was in uh he was in an
ied attack over there
uh his leg
was hit with shrapnel and then through
an ambush a bullet also hit him
and obviously hospitalized for a long
time
and when he came out i was visiting home
and saw him over the holidays and
we were talking about it and he just
said something that was mind blowing to
me
he said uh you know he was fortunate
because he had a family that
he could go and stay with but dealing
with like a lot of the bureaucracy
around um the uh you know
support for the veterans uh he was
saying that a lot of the guys he knew in
the hospital went straight from the
hospital to the streets if they didn't
have a place to go because their
disability pay would take
so long to uh to be able to come in
and that just boggled my mind and so i
spent about two years on and off in my
free time just getting to know a lot of
homeless vets a lot of them in new york
went down to dc and met
a couple and just wherever i would go i
try to find
someone to speak to and just hear their
stories and some of them i spent a
couple days with
walking in the distance kind of
observing seeing how people portrayed
them how they handled social situations
one of them was sleeping in a car out in
the woods
another one i spent a night under a
bridge with uh
just trying to as much as i could
understand that
and then bring it to life in in a way
that
i was hoping for other people like me
who are naive about the reality that our
combat vets face coming back home
i was hoping it would be an eye-opener
to kind of walk in their shoes for an
hour and a half
and get a sort of unflinching look at
the struggles emotional physical
uh systemic and social that they deal
with
and i was pleasantly surprised when it
all came out
that veterans themselves who i
didn't think would be as into it because
they've already lived it um
but how it really became an important
film for a lot of
of actual combat vets who felt like
watching that they did they're like well
if some filmmaker told the story must
not
just be me so it helped some of them
realize
they're not alone in that struggle that
there's others out there that are
dealing with
same issues you know they have such a
self-reliance that's bred into them
through through their military training
through
you know their literally i mean their
forces of nature when they're
in combat and they come back and they're
dealing with these issues and it's
almost an embarrassment to admit that
they're dealing with depression that
they're dealing with social isolation
financial issues all that sort of stuff
and so to to showcase it in that way
where they can see that
this is a systemic issue it's not a
personal flaw theirs
that it's something that's happening to
a lot of people
it's great to see that response to it as
well
um obviously it was something that was
personally really important to me
uh it was also
in my own way i'm something that's
politically i trying to be too
heavy-handed in my films but i was
very much an anti-war advocate back in
the early days and
still am the early days of those wars
and it was to me it was a way to make an
anti-war
film that would speak to
pro-war people and let them see you know
it's not
um it's not about uh whether the war was
right or wrong it's about the
aftermath of it and so if you're going
to start a war
think about the consequences of it what
you're going to be doing to those men
and women we send over there
uh and so that it was great to see the
conversations i
started i mean for such a small film
that really uh
i was proud of the impact it had
right i did you watch a lot of films
like coming home and things like that
from the vietnam era
this is almost embarrassing i didn't
even know about the film coming home
until uh one of the reviews of
frey actually mentioned like compared it
to coming home i was like oh
um i'd actually hadn't seen rambo the
first one at the time i'd seen some of
the later ones i hadn't seen the first
one at the time
i hadn't seen born on the fourth of july
uh but i had seen
hurt locker i'd seen apocalypse now
platoon so i've seen a lot of actual
war movies and some of them that touch
on those aspects of
the coming home experience but one of my
main things about it was
some of the the kind of newer braid of
films that was coming out around that
time about the war and about
that experience i felt like there was
still so much
melodrama that was brought into it um
almost like a hollywoodization of the
story
and because it was such a low budget
film it was just mine
i had the commercial career to survive
on i wasn't concerned if it ever made a
dime i just wanted
to make one that showed it in its most
authentic way
even brian the actor who played the main
character
uh you know he spent some time with a
home for
uh kind of like a halfway home for uh
homeless vets or dealing with like
addiction issues and stuff like that got
to know a lot of them really well
and one of our main focuses on it was to
you know there was no score in the movie
his acting was very naturalistic
there's only a few big flare-ups a lot
of the time it was more him trying to
suppress those those feelings and not
show his weaknesses
or what he was struggling with um
and just like if at any moment this
feels like someone's watching a movie
you and i have failed you know we would
talk about like as an actor and as a
director we failed if this feels like a
movie
i would want it to feel like an
experience and
one of the best compliments i've ever
gotten and brian as well
i was after our premiere there was a
gentleman there who was a marine combat
vet and he
he told brian he's like every moment of
that film i've lived and a lot of it i
still live every day
and i believed you were a marine up
until i saw you do push-ups
and i was like no he's an actor
[Laughter]
so it was just it was great to see that
kind of response i mean
it was it was a gamble um you know it's
not an exciting film it's a very uh
as a buddy put it he's like i'm not
i didn't enjoy it but i'm really glad i
watched it
um it's uh it's a film that's a
challenge for for the audience it's
supposed to be a little upsetting it's
supposed to be slow at times it's
repetitive it shows
his day-to-day cycles of dealing with
the same issues over and over again and
how
that unravels his um
almost his willingness to cope with it
and uh
um you know there's no
loose ends that are tied up at the end
characters drop off left and right
because often times when a ptsd
attack happens a lot of the vets i know
they would just flee
um you know they would disappear that go
inward
and it would sever they would sever ties
with people
and so address that in there so
characters don't have arcs in it because
a lot of times in life there isn't a
full arc
um so it's not a
it's not a typical story in that way but
i thought it was essential to do it that
way because it's the most effective way
to express the real struggle of somebody
like that
and i think you said that you had maybe
thought of doing a documentary but you
couldn't bring yourself to film them
so then you turned it into a narrative
yeah is that correct that is
that's exactly it i really you know a
lot of those vets that i was going
around and meeting and getting to
you know to try and understand it i was
i would bring a camera with me
with the intent of at some point getting
them on camera talking about it and
showing their life
but you know a lot of them were very
guarded about
this again it's not something that you
know nobody's proud of being homeless
nobody's going to talk openly about it a
lot of them
were embarrassed at where they were at
didn't like to admit the struggles they
were having
and even just the fact they trusted me
to open up to and to let me do that i
mean sometimes it would take
a few meetings for them and um to get to
really
be comfortable with me and understand
that i had the best of intentions
and was just there to listen um not
coming in with an agenda
and so by the time they would finally
open up and start talking about the last
thing i wanted to do is throw a camera
in their face i was just like that just
felt to me vulgar to even think about
so i would just sit and listen and um
you know almost be just somebody for
them to talk to
and it was amazing how how much they
were willing to share with me
for that and so i just realized like i
can do
i can do inspiring documentaries for
somebody who's talking about overcoming
adversity i can talk
you know do that kind of thing but
getting into like that
i actually had the pleasure of meeting
now eugene jarecki one time and asked
him how he does it because
some of the interviews he does are i
mean i
i just seen the house i live in and he's
interviewing a guy who's been sentenced
to prison
you know 20 year old guy and uh asked
him afterwards like how he
how he can even do that and he's like
his camera was exact words or something
like i feel like a monster doing it but
i just keep on thinking about the end
goal it's like this is more important
for other people to see this than for me
to feel good about recording it
um and i admire him as a documentarian
to be able to overcome
that sense of guilt in that moment but
uh
for me it was just easier to take in all
that
and then craft it into a narrative based
on those real stories
and tell it that way and i also feel
like
in the end it was the right choice
beyond just my own creative struggles
with being a documentarian
it was the right choice because it
reached an audience that a documentary
would not have reached uh you know
people that were open to watching it
in its film forum form
may not have been as open to it in a
documentary which oftentimes
documentaries are kind of
perceived to already have a political or
social agenda
this film wasn't necessarily perceived
that way
and overtly it doesn't
it just kind of shows this is what it is
make of it what you will
but yeah uh so that's a part of why the
film had that naturalistic tone
and even the the short film you'd
mentioned was sort of an experiment to
see if i could pull it off because
i hadn't done i hadn't done a very
naturalistic film before my
shorts and experiments before that were
a little bit more in the uh
i would say in the uh you know oliver
stone over the top sort of mold
um so it was a new way for me to kind of
go into this
more natural realistic approach
and yeah i'm glad i did it that way
because it was uh it was a huge learning
curve for me as well as just an
incredible experience at what point did
you realize though this is not just
going to be a little indie film that'll
live
on youtube i think you said just for a
few friends to see
what point did it cross over to a new
new audience
it really yeah it was uh when i started
up on it i
definitely had the sense that nobody was
gonna watch it
um like this is just i mean it's not a
it's not a fun movie
to watch and uh um
you know even the festival circuit uh
which was a fascinating on its own
uh you know we started getting awards
which i was shocked by
um and uh
um but even then like with the
distribution process
you know signed up with indie rights and
linda and michael at indian rights are
just godsends they're great people
uh but um it was literally the day of
our premiere our theatrical premiere
in la here and i was on the balcony with
linda and we just got in the la times
review we had a quarter page review with
our picture
you know picture of the film and it was
a phenomenal review
linda says to me she's like you starting
to think maybe you have a good film now
i'm like
everybody else seems to think so so i
guess so
um it really it was shocking to me
because
i mean i guess any creative goes through
this when you look back at your film as
or as you're working on it you see
nothing but flaws and failure and things
you wish you'd done differently
and it wasn't until the second night of
the screening
where we had a guest who came his name
was sergeant justin bond he was a
army vet from uh who had been in
the fight in fallujah and lost his leg
in it
and he and i were having a great chat
before the film and sat next to each
other
through the screening of the film it was
amazing to experience it that way
because
sitting next to this guy who's truly
lived the story i
made a film about and there were moments
where i got a little chuckle for him
every now and then he'd whisper
some little snide remark in my ear but
also you could feel his emotions going
through and so i almost got to
experience it
fresh through him being able to
kind of see it how he was seeing it for
the first time
and that was the first time i ever got
to actually experience my
my own film and enjoy it um it was
very grateful for that experience for uh
for being able to see it through his
eyes in a way in terms of just having
his reactions right next to me while he
was seeing it
and being like oh oh that did work okay
so yeah it wasn't really until the
second day of our theatrical premiere
that i felt like okay
this film is actually decent and it's
going to go somewhere
and then it was a few few weeks later
back in new york a
gentleman who was a army psychologist in
afghanistan was back giving a talk
to a handful of doctors in new york
about ptsd and he invited me to
it and literally told the doctors
at this meeting when he ended it he
would reference the film a few times and
even a clip from it that he showed
but he said if you want to understand
what our vets go through when they come
back home
watch this gentleman's film and pointed
to me
and so afterwards you know talked with a
few of the doctors told them where they
could watch it stuff like that
um so there's moments like that where
really was like okay this
this was actually it's a small indie
film but it was something special it
really
just the people that it was intended to
hit it really hit
i find that interesting though because
you you said before i think in another
interview
that anything that could have been said
about your film or maybe other films
you've maybe said worse about your own
work
and i'm wondering if that almost makes
someone better
that um i hope all the self-abuse isn't
just
just a waste of time um it uh
it is i mean i try to always look for
the positive in what i'm
doing obviously it's what keeps me going
but
yeah the self-criticism i really i mean
i've gotten some bad reviews in the past
and every single one of them like oh
yeah i can see that that makes sense
you know uh the only one that i didn't
get and this was it was an amazon
comment was they
they said they hated this the music and
fray i'm like
there's no score you're talking about
there had to be some troll yeah that was
the only one i've ever disagreed with
there was a comment on imdb about frey
and
i thought it was interesting that you
incorporated this part that you
mentioned earlier about the
self-reliance
and i think the commenter or the the
reviewer put
um that the main character and fray
justin rejects anything he interprets as
charity
yeah did you pick up on that from
meeting these vets
when you saw them definitely in fact
there's a line in the short film
uh this uh gentleman uh this older guy
offers him he's walked on the street
it's rainy day offers him a ride and
after he drops him off um
at uh basically at the edge of the
forest where
the uh the character is sleeping uh he
offers him uh
he's like i got some groceries in the
back and i gave you something like a
beer or something
and there's a moment where uh justin the
veteran
hesitates and the guy says to him it's
not charity it's thanks
and he takes it and that was kind of the
theme of that short film was the idea of
like
you know these things that we need to do
to help our returning combat vets it's
not about
charity it's a thanks it's for what you
know what they've sacrificed
um and that was to a lot of returning
vets again it's that self-reliance pride
they don't want charity they don't see
themselves as a charity case
and so um and
you know it's not just with vets i mean
you know
i've i've seen even in my own life as an
artist i've had my ups and downs
sometimes where
you know you don't want to ask for help
and
but you need it and you know what that
does to your psyche when you feel
when you feel like a charity case and so
i really wanted to address that and kind
of brought my own
personal experiences with being down and
out
having to sleep on somebody's sofa or
not knowing how you're going to eat and
having to ask a friend for ten dollars
or whatever it might be
um try to bring that into it and just
show that it's okay to be down and out
sometimes like everybody
has the potential to fall through the
cracks um it doesn't make you a bad
person it doesn't mean that you failed
uh it just means that as
as a society we should help lift each
other up and so i kind of wanted to
express that in the film the best i
could within within that story there was
actually i mentioned earlier when uh
brian had spent some time with this home
with uh
vets he mentioned that there was a
construction site across the street
at one point somebody just a big two by
four or some
something had fallen and clapped against
some other wood
and he said it was fascinating for him
to observe the reaction of the
vets there versus his own like to him
was like oh what was that
to them it was like on guard like um
just immediate response even vietnam
vets guys i've been back for
35 40 years terrible with math however
long it's been
you know older gentleman who had been
back a long time would steal that
that loud sound out of nowhere just set
him on guard
and uh so yeah yeah the fireworks are
not good for
for that at all no and there were a lot
of them this year
yeah how has your directing style
evolved from your first film to now
uh thankfully it's evolved from my first
film
early on i really was much more
focused on uh
story and theme oftentimes at the
expense
of uh the
really the film experience uh and
over time and just through just
repetition of trying
you know uh shooting constantly learning
more about it
um to me it's much more now about the
psychology and
the visceral experience
you know still enjoy some good dialogue
that sort of thing but really it's to me
it's not about what's said
as much as about what is experienced by
the audience
and that was the biggest change for me
conceptually which has really changed
the way that i approach
directing now one of the biggest things
for me
has been getting to a point where i
trust my actors to know the character as
well if not better than i do
so that way the choices they make on
screen are natural to them
that it's not me telling them to do this
it's them
deciding that's what the character
needed to do
this is what the character would have
done in that moment
same thing with really almost any
department on a film
i want whoever is there i want them to
feel empowered that they're there
because they know exactly what this film
needs for that moment there's been times
where that hasn't worked i've had to
step in and
take a more dictator type approach
um but most the time i really like
having
that sort of environment on set where
everybody feels
like they are an active contributor to
the creative output of the film to what
it's actually saying
um but again especially with actors i
think it's just so key
that they feel comfortable and that
they're not being
judged that they're not you know i don't
ever want them to feel like they made
the wrong choice i'll say something like
instead of saying
oh no don't do it that way do it this
way instead i'll say
that was great but how if we try it this
way um
that was really good but let's just try
maybe a little bit more
uh a little bit more anger or a little
bit more
sarcasm or something like that and try
to find those ways to where they always
they never feel like they did it wrong
and vanya the lead in blood from stone
he started joking with me about it
whenever he said he did it great like
you mean i sucked
like no he didn't suck
[Laughter]
um so he caught on to some of my tricks
uh
but it really is it's it's uh because it
is initially a wrong
choice there is no wrong choice uh it's
all about
you know knowing how to get it to where
i wanted to go and honestly one of the
greatest things for me as a director
is all the work i've done as an editor
and
as a dep i really i didn't set out to do
either of those
i just did them out of necessity because
i had no budgets uh
and so you know you got i just had to
figure it out myself
um but doing that especially like you
know doing interviews
for clients you know we do an hour-long
interview and i have to edit it into a
one-minute video
um all that type of stuff over the years
has helped me when i'm directing when
i'm watching a scene
i can see it and edit it in my mind and
know
we got that line we got that line oh no
we didn't get that line
okay that was a decent and then i can
kind of just keep that organized in my
brain so that i don't yell
or i don't say that you know to move on
to the next
scene or the next part until i know
we've gotten all it takes we need for it
to come together and editing
and that's been a huge huge help because
early on
i was just never sure if we had it i'm
like i think we do and i get into
editing i'm like oh
no no we didn't get it uh so that's been
a huge help too
is just finding you know finding those
great moments and being able to file it
away in my brain like
seeing the edit as it's happening and
even to a certain extent my
screenwriting i mean i write
an edited film i mean this uh
fray and this one the the scene count is
obscene
because it's a lot of back and forth
between
scenes um so literally my script
is almost verbatim what you see on
camera
with the exception of some improv by the
actors
but uh scene organization uh
just everything flows exactly as it is
in the final film
there's only uh one one scene that got
cut and one that
or two that got shortened a little bit
jeff can we talk about the budget for
frey
i understand you financed it through
various jobs yeah
yeah so um i was i was kind of fortunate
after i did the short film the little
experiment for fray
um we literally wrapped that on the day
that the housing market
and lehman uh collapsed um
which was a terrible time to just spend
your meager savings on a film and then
not have a job for six months um and so
but i was kind of fortunate in a way
that after those six months when
companies started hiring again
they weren't they didn't have the
budgets to go with the big ad agencies
and i had a couple of my fashion clients
that were like well this jeff guy that's
been doing our uh
you know internals and our in-store
videos this stuff's
basically as good as the agencies we
hire let's just have him do our
commercials
and so i kind of got really lucky um
started
landing a couple of you know i mean they
were hiring me
much less than what they would hire for
a big production company or an
agency but for me it was a lot and so
i was able to put away some savings uh
over the course about two years
and um was able to pull it off and then
also just lucky and i wrote it with
brian in mind he and i had done the
short film and we'd known each other a
while
knowing you know that i had jaren as my
cinematographer on it who
uh you know obviously is one of the
best cinematographers of this generation
you know i've always felt that way
fortunately he's kind of gotten there
now
having jody as the producer you know had
a great circle of friends that brought
to life
and then shooting in oregon was a huge
help too um
you know it was a lot of people there
one they believed in the story
they really believed in what we were
trying to do with it so we got
um you know uh we got people all the
all the cars for the film were donated
to us
uh all the locations with exception of
two we got for free we got the wood mill
for free
we just had to have insurance
you know just so much we were able to
get and people were so
helpful with it the employment agency
seen actually when we were
talking to the woman who owned that
actual employment agency
she said that if we needed extras she
would reach out to her
network of uh people who were looking
for work
so that's how i really get so many
extras for the film uh
it was just um yeah so in terms like
pulling it off for a smaller budget
it was um it just took a lot of favors
uh but um you know like i said because i
that commercial world
you know was our budget on that was
probably the craft services budget for
like
an a24 film um
but it was still enough that we were
able to pull off something with all
those
all those other people really putting
their heart and soul into it
and one of my proudest things about that
was
so many of the local people that worked
on it it did end up elevating their
careers some of them was their first
film they'd ever worked on
and you know i wrote everybody a letter
recommendation for whatever they wanted
to do because i'm like
if you worked on this film you had your
hands in every department so
um i mean there were there were entire
days where was literally myself
jaron brian another whoever the other
actor was
and matt who was a pa like that was the
entirety of our production it was just
you know it was three people and two
actors or three actors at a time
for days on end so as a you know
everybody on it just put in so much and
so they
a lot of their careers got elevated by
it which was so great to see
because we've all worked on no budget
films that when we were done with like
well that was a waste of three days or
five days or whatever so knowing that
the people that came on board were able
to go on and do
more afterwards and were elevated by
this film was just
something i was really proud of as well
because
it's a hard industry so being able to
help lift others up is
is a good feeling so you knew how much
you had in this
bank account or bank accounts or
whatever when when you started to dip
past a certain point and and maybe the
clock was ticking
what was your mindset uh
um i when
when the funds were running low it was
uh it was nerve-racking had to
compartmentalize
because the the anxiety meltdown that
was happening just put that in this box
over here
and this box over here is like well if
you don't finish the film then you just
ruined your life for nothing
so um it was and
we actually had we took a three-day
hiatus because i had a client that
wanted me to do a commercial
a little web commercial it was like yeah
we'll put on hiatus i
literally took the last of the money i
had and gave it to jaron who was stuck
in portland for
three days um while i was away and
you know basically went back to new york
did a shoot and flew right back
i didn't get paid for it for another
month but at least had that
coming in and then really grateful
marissa the lead actress in it her
parents
gave uh i should remember this i think
it was two thousand dollars to us to
help out
um my own parents threw in a thousand
dollars
um and helped cover some of the hotel
costs for us
so you know it was fortunate like family
and friends really pitched in
my girlfriend at the time kim she set up
a paypal account where people could make
donations that helped bring a couple
hundred more dollars in
um just really just crawled across the
finish line
and uh and then when i when we wrapped
you know got back to new york and just
took like the next three months just
doing as much client work as i could
because
um i wasn't going to have a home for
much longer if i didn't
and i didn't want art to uh or life to
imitate art that much
so so it sounds like it was kind of
rah-rah out of the gate and then
piecemeal at the end it was that's kind
of how you finished it
yeah it was i mean definitely we knew i
mean the budget
was so small and i guess at this point i
can say i mean we literally went into
this shoot with just over twenty
thousand dollars
um obviously we spent a lot more over
the course of the film
but that was what we're starting with on
it and
uh that's not a lot uh that doesn't
stretch very far when you're trying to
when you've got to fly
some cast and crew out to new york and
house them and feed them
or out from new york to oregon house and
feed them
transportation logistical costs and uh
you know just some other checks would
come in from
projects i'd done a few months before
add that to the budget
um and again my girlfriend at the time
kim she was managing uh
managing all the finances she would
watch my bank account and tell me where
i was at and
she'd be like you guys need to spend
less money on coffee like i can't
that's that's not a compromise we can
make
right especially not in oregon no i
don't know the coffee are they
comparable to
yeah seattle yeah yeah um there was a
place uh that we were just hooked on
and brian still talked about to this day
he's like i just i want to go back for
their coffee
um yeah it was uh it was intense
that's for sure uh every dollar on that
one mattered i mean
all the wardrobe that we bought came
from goodwill
uh you know again and just
every favor we could get was uh was a
was just essential i mean if we hadn't
gotten all the favors we had gotten
there's no way that film would have
happened
so and sorry you shot right before the
actual quote-unquote meltdown the the
lima brothers
that was the short film uh poor the one
that does an experiment for frey
so that was right before that meltdown
so i guess i was ahead of the curve in
terms of talking about uh
you know just financial precarity uh and
obviously it inspired the script
in this one you know thus why marissa's
character is a teacher of uh
morals and uh economics um
uh i forget the specific term which is
terrible but uh but yeah
so you know wedge that in there in terms
of as a way to discuss some of those
higher ideas without being too
heavy-handed i hope
um but yeah i was definitely heavily
inspired by that
because you know it just it's so easy to
fall through the cracks as an artist
i've seen it you know as a freelancer
and an
artist you know it's feast or famine
sometimes things are great and then
you know buy a new set of lenses and
then you don't get a job for six months
you're like oh god that was a stupid
choice
and so you know i know how easy it is
and granted for me a lot of those
financial decisions
are not essentials a set of lenses isn't
an essential it's a good business
investment i mean
i've used the same set of lenses now for
six seven
years and they're gorgeous
staying with camera you know drop 20 30
grand on a camera that's a lot of money
that's
you know it's a new car for a nice new
car and
all that but that pays itself back over
time
yet those are still expenses that are
huge and
you know you hit a dry spell with work
and you're like oh god i'm not gonna be
able to make rent now
so those are all things that i took from
my experiences over the years and try to
work into it and make
it feel authentic you know i i can
see how somebody could easily just tire
of the rat race and just that constant
trying to keep your head above water
and just step out like i'm just i'm
gonna go live in the woods
uh i'm gonna go sleep under a bridge i'm
not gonna stress it
uh there's actually there's even a
homeless gentleman who slipped my subway
station that every now and then i'd
come home with a bottle of wine or a
bottle of whiskey or something like that
and we'd sit on the
bench on the subway platform and just
chat and he was that way
he said he just got tired of trying to
survive because he's like
this isn't an easy life but at least i
don't have the
i don't have the worries that i had and
so wanted to bring back to it is just
that idea of
the struggle just the day-to-day
struggle that so many people face
and don't have a way out of i feel so
fortunate that as a filmmaker that i can
go and do a commercial
and live off of that for a month or two
or three months
and then go back to my writing and my
editing and stuff like that like that's
such a luxury to be able to have that
that most people don't have that ability
to
get that magical check that's what the
lottery's you know
so popular for um and so
yeah i just wanted to try and express
that in a in a film and show
show to people who may be a little bit
more fortunate that it's really easy for
people to
to lose their grip and give up hope
we have a quote here from variety about
your new film blood from stone
a genre defying vampire film yes but why
hasn't this been done before
that's a good question um it was i
this idea had been fermenting in the
back of my head to do kind of a
wacky vampire film but you know we hit
the
true blood and twilight years where just
vampires were
everywhere and then you have films like
what we do in the shadows that are just
i mean perfect vampire satires
it's like okay i can't there's nothing i
can do in that
realm that's going to top that film or
even be of any value anymore
um then there's films like uh let the
right one in that are just
gorgeous beautiful coming of age art
films that also deal with ideas of
immortality
so it was definitely one of those things
that was just kept on the back burner
because like i have nothing of value to
bring to this genre
um or to the vampire films and then
just personal experience uh lost uh
grandfather
and reflecting on that it was for me it
was this idea of
this man who was from another era who
good person in his heart and a good
grandfather but also somebody that after
john wayne stopped making movies and uh
you know cultural and social changes
happened with uh
you know us white guys not having all
the power anymore
um it wasn't his era anymore
and he didn't like where the world was
going he didn't feel like he belonged
here anymore
and kind of just gave up on life but
didn't die for 25 years
and so i grew up with his grandfather
who just really wasn't happy with the
world i wasn't happy with still being a
part of it
and uh started thinking like that's kind
of a fascinating angle on it is this
idea
of an immortal somebody who's been here
200 years he comes from the days when he
could
or 400 years where he could ransack a
village and
you know what do you do uh you blame it
on angry gods and you
you move on with your life um what would
he do in this new era where
attitudes have changed technology has
changed and
um that's what i've jokingly called it
uh
leaving las vegas meets natural-born
killers because
it's almost there's some parallels the
nicholas cage character
and uh leaving las vegas this guy that's
just he's done he's out
he's just trying to numb himself to it
all and speed up his
exit so deals with those sorts of ideas
and really using the vampire idea
as a way to explore some deeper themes
while it's still being entertaining
uh you know one of my favorite films is
samsara which is
kind of about the cyclical nature of
existence and the rise and fall of
civilizations
and trying to escape this cycle this
perpetual cycle of rise and fall
and creation destruction that we're on
um
beautiful film uh but
not exactly a uh you know typical crowd
pleaser and so trying to take themes
like that but do it through the vampire
idea of old eras and new eras
uh creation destruction um and the
cyclical nature of things to
for characters that have seen those
cycles i've seen
a few of them and it's all kind of
repetition to them whereas
to us the daily news is catastrophic
to them they've seen it all and done it
all
and so kind of exploring those ideas and
that's where
even ideas like i brought in a lot of
iconography and tropes of westerns of
newer films uh films
that are thought of as from another era
and showing them in this more modern
kind of indie context where it's gritty
and a little rougher
and just contrasting that the music
score of being a
blend of synthesizers and rootsy
banjo and lap steel and just showing
like these clash
different eras and different genres into
this
fight between the old and the new that
we see so much of in our
current political and social environment
so
that's where i think that genre define
comes from is that it's not a horror
film
in the truest sense it's not uh
just you know it's not a romance it's
not a western it's not a nor
it's kind of all those in
um at least that was the hope and i've
been saying since day one there was a
good chance this film could be a total
train wreck
because it's just trying to do a lot of
things
at once but so far from initial
reactions it seems to have worked
it seems that people are enjoying it i
love the night shoots especially
you had these great shots where maybe
the
scene itself was about something very
you know
violent but beautiful desert background
with a moon
and a cactus and i just wondered how did
you pull that off and what kind of
lighting did you use
that was the magic of
very recent technologies uh that was the
sony a7 3s
i think that was the model i'm so bad
with the name the number letter combos
which is you know small dslr camera
that low-light capabilities are
ridiculous
um i was so nervous when i wrote it i'm
like how am i gonna do desert exteriors
with no budget we can't light a desert
um just trying to think of how we could
pull that off
and then that camera came out and i did
some tests with it
and was like holy crap i can see a
horizon line in the desert at night
and so got a pl mount for it
put some high speed primes on it and we
shot
all the car interiors uh with the and
from
or the the crazy uh rideshare scene
that was all shot on that thing um all
the desert night exteriors were shot
with
it and literally no lighting
um just the moon headlights from the car
in one of the shots or actually two of
them
um and then the glow of the city from
the distance
that was our lighting it was literally
just natural light
to be able to pull off night exteriors
and then using some uh
neat videos uh denoiser and post to get
rid of the obscene amount of grain in it
to pull off that kind of
level of low light um and yeah it
uh it looks awesome i was like
pleasantly surprised with how well
those night exteriors turned out i
thought they were gonna be just a grainy
nasty muddy mess
but i love how they look yeah they're
beautiful
and this is just a small thing but i
noticed three characters wore
robes yes when and it was what was the
significance of that it was almost like
the 30 there was this beautiful
even the one that he wears is sort of
sort of more thrift shop style but
there was a very cool sort of theme of
these robes
thanks yeah it was uh the rope his robe
in it was
uh was intended it was really hard to
find a a
floral uh really well used robe that fit
vania but uh
we were able it was scripted as
basically the idea is he's supposed to
be kind of a squatter in this home it's
obviously not his home
from the decorations to that sort of
thing uh
and so that was the idea there
and then with uh with the other two it
just kind of
to me it was it's like basically it's a
way to kind of showcase the characters
and their distinct personalities but
also
they're the like they're the only three
vampires so it's kind of just it was
almost like a uniform in a way for them
like their comfort level um that was
although on a deeper level there really
wasn't anything to the robes it was just
kind of i wanted to show
them in their environment their most
like comfortable
natural sort of relaxed state
but didn't have like a deeper theme so
maybe there'll be something audiences
pull from it i always i'm always in
always enjoy that when someone says
something i'm like
i wish i thought of that i'm going to
use that i was i was really smart
but not with the robes and then the
convention
at the bar and sort of this attitude of
that they almost didn't have to behave
because they were out of their element i
guess
living in la we see that with a lot of
tourists sometimes you know especially
if you're in santa monica or wherever
you can see sort of these the people
that forget that they have to still
engage amongst society and they and they
you know it's like a big fun
you know thing and i thought that was
interesting how you showed very subtle
things of these men at this
convention and yeah if you've ever
worked a convention or something maybe
i've
i worked in uh i was a waiter for long
enough and did enough
catering and stuff like that i've worked
some events like that and
to me was so the the three main male
characters and i don't want to give away
too many
spoilers here but the three main male
characters you have vania who's just
i mean the guy looks like jason mamoa um
this is a giant beast of a man
um and then you have the mic characters
the convention go or then the raymond
character the doctor and
to me like the raymond one and the vania
and vania's character yuri they're like
the um
sort of like dual lands of male
archetypes you have
vania the super alpha male who is
all in it for himself and then the
rayman character who is
the much softer more social creature
who's interest introverted
and finds his value and how he can be of
benefit to others instead of vanya's all
about how what he can acquire for
himself
and with uh the my character the
convention goer
he was to me this the guy who by nature
should be more of a raymond but due to
social conditioning and the idea of
wanting to be the alpha macho cool guy
he's trying to be more of the the ure
character the
the the cool guy that is suave and
handsome and funny and all that
and he fails miserably at it and so it
was kind of
um maybe an overused term now but it was
kind of showcasing like the effects of
that that
messaging of masculinity and
how it's shown in media and what a guy
is supposed to be and
sort of showing how that can become so
just ugly um
you know it's like kind of just be true
to who you are
i've always you know joked i've never
had troubles with
anyone that questions my own masculinity
because i don't
have it it's like i just i am who
i am i never wanted to be that alpha guy
and so i kind of wanted to show you know
but you see that in others like when
you're trying to be someone you're not
you become a very toxic
person and so like just embrace who you
are so that was kind of that idea of
those convention goers like when they're
in that element it's like
he's his character when he's just
talking to daria he's actually a sweet
nice guy
when he's with his convention buddies he
has to act like he's the cool alpha dude
and so you see that sort of toxic ugly
side of him come out
so that was kind of the idea with
exploring it in that vein and then
anyone that's been to you know the
casinos and stuff
knows that the conventions are you know
that's half their income i i would
imagine is
at least from maybe not the gambling but
definitely from the hotels and stuff
like that is trying to get conventions
there and so
anytime you're at a casino there's going
to be a convention there so just kind of
part of the
part of the casino life yeah
i thought and then set against the the
people gambling the sort of sad
desperation of this jackpot is going to
do it
this this last one exactly and same with
in the convention it's all about the
sale
you know even when he's sitting there
with them they're talking about
acquiring the woman and acquiring the
sale that's literally the
the two themes that they they talk about
is uh
you know out in the casinos it's all
these people throwing their funds into
they're hoping they get that jackpot and
just
you know kind of kind of the idea and
uh it was actually a guy that helped the
stunts in it carl he uh
uh came on he's an uh wonderful guy and
he said uh
to him it was fascinating when he was
there he goes you almost feel like
the vampires are more alive than the
actual living people
uh and that was kind of the idea of it
is just showing like
this this constant hunt
for some life-sustaining you know
whether it's the the the money from a
jackpot the sale
all that like this is like almost like a
vampire culture
that has uh you know
kind of become our our uh commercial
society
jeff we found this quote from you i
think you said i wanted to create
something that people will walk away
from thinking
i've never seen anything like that
before a small indie like this can't
compete with hollywood for
spectacle and star power but we can try
to make much more interesting films at
least
can you expand on that yeah um yeah i
definitely wanted to
wanted to make something that yeah that
when people walked away from
they didn't just forget about it uh
and you know if i forget i should
remember
i want to see his career brick but they
some director i remember
reading years ago said i don't care if
they love it or hate it i want them to
remember it
and that to me that's i have more
respect and i enjoy watching films that
go for the gusto
and fail over those that just try to
appeal
to the most common denominator that's
why not a big fan of superhero movies
but i
appreciate the dc ones 100 times over
the marvel ones
because dc made some steamers
but they're always like they always try
to do something
that's really over the top and
interesting or whatever
and whereas marvel like they all kind of
bleed together it's
and there's no consequences and you get
into that but even just in the indie
film world
how do you compete with those movies i
mean they've got
they spend more on uh you know i'm sure
their xerox budget than i had for this
whole film
um just to and so you know i'm not gonna
allow do them in action or spectacle
and uh star power but i can at least
try and um i can at least try and give
the audience something
that they're gonna walk away feeling
like i got a unique experience from this
and so with that like the intent was
not necessarily to make something that's
the hard part about doing that is you
don't want to make something that's
uh too um can't think of the word right
now you don't want to make it where
it's too abstract or like audiences
aren't gonna feel like
like it's worth committing to it um
still make it entertaining still make it
fun
you know it's uh i try to keep it
fast-paced a little bit of a slow burn
like it has a slow build but once it
kicks in it's i could try to give it a
good pace
there's a lot of just there is some
spectacle in it at least for a small
indie
but then thematically i don't like
i don't like things that fit into a neat
little box so
uh musicians i like often do a lot of
fusion type of stuff
they mix different genres
and same with filmmakers you know some
of the films that
inspired me when i was first kind of
getting my start in the night you know
as a teenager in the 90s you know
watching
tarantino stuff which is often
unclassifiable for a genre
um watching you know uh movies like
california
like i guess it's a thriller but it's
also
it's funny i mean i still quote that
movie brad pitt's
my arguably my favorite role next to his
his role in true romance
um which is another one uh natural born
killers
uh some of these films that
go dark and they're like they kind of
challenge your own morality as an
audience but at the same time they're
funny they have characters that you fall
in love with
uh even though they're horrible and uh
um
and just you know deal with deeper human
themes and social and political themes
so i kind of fell in love with movies
like that and i feel like
we have an industry that needs to sell
things and so they need to know how to
sell it so it needs to be a certain
product
and that in a way has really
homogenized so much of storytelling
and my own little way i wanted to try
and like break out of that and not
not think about oh well this is a horror
movie so i can't do this
or if i do this um you know fans of the
vampire genre are gonna be like well
this isn't a real vampire movie
um and more just let the let the story
go where it needs to go to be the story
it needs to be
uh without worrying about making it
marketable
now unfortunately for my distributors
makes their job a lot harder it's funny
you mentioned the movie california from
was that 1993
yeah that's it okay because the
bartender in your film the opening
scenes
reminded me of juliet lewis she had a
very similar
sort of not just look but the sort of
the character type as well
yeah you know what and uh
we that julia lewis character and julia
lewis any movie is one of my favorites
uh she's just phenomenal but in that one
she is
she's just i mean phenomenal so
both adorable and trashy
and um and
i just i absolutely love her in that
movie as well and so
i'm sure on some level like
just stylistically those movies
definitely impacted
uh you know on blood from stone i was
the uh this wardrobe
and stylist person as well so um
you know basically every article in
clothing you see in that i
not only found it purchased or at the
very least agreed to
but um yeah so i'm sure my own styling
of the movie was probably heavily
inspired by
by that film and that goes back to what
you said too about not everybody wants
these like
films that are in a neat little box
these popcorn movies some people
want the the juliet lewis protagonist
and and can relate to that more than
nothing against sandra bullock but her
characters i
admire sandra's career but her
characters are always sort of very
similar
and sort of this like savior you know
middle class i'm gonna
fix everything and not all of us can
totally relate to that
and again nothing against it but i think
it has to be something
a little like there is a damaged quality
to some of juliet's roles and i yeah
i like that well yeah julia lewis always
brings such a vulnerability
even in natural born killers i mean
she's ferocious in that
and yet you know the flashbacks to her
childhood the
the hostile relationships that she has
with woody harrelson's character
um you can understand where her anger is
coming from like it's never
even when she's a monster she plays it
in a way where you still feel some sense
of
sympathy for her or at the very least
empathy like you're like i
understand why she's acting that way and
that to me i mean that's a that's a
great
villain and i also about those movies i
mean the villain was the main characters
in those movies
um you know kind of anti-heroes if you
want to call them that
and you know there's got to be something
redeeming there was a great quote that
said uh
even the devil's convinced himself he's
doing the right thing
so you know with any of these you know
villain characters or anti-heroes if you
don't feel like you can understand why
they're doing it
then it's not a good character and
juliet lewis is phenomenal at portraying
that
did your distributor or indie rights
give you the idea for a vampire movie or
that's something that you
came up with and pitched it to them so
um
obviously i met you know met michael
linda through frey and indy rights was
just phenomenal for that film uh and has
anybody that's
ever gone through distribution knows
it's a nightmare process when you find a
good distributor
cling to them and uh um being become
good friends and we're at dinner one
night and i was uh
talking with them and i had recently
come across a notepad that had this
kind of some notes of this film so i was
telling them about about it just the
initial ideas for it and the next day
michael texted me and basically said
this should be your next film this is
something that
could actually sell um
and so i started thinking i was like
well you know
frey was great and i mean i'm fortunate
it actually made its budget back and
turned mildly profitable
off of you know fairly modest budget but
it's a film i never expected to make a
dime off of
but if i want to actually have a career
making films i should probably do one
that
has the potential to make money um you
know
and so uh so yeah i've decided
uh if i could find a way to make it work
for me that this would be the film to do
and that's when
really reflecting on it and finding you
know and it was literally right around
the time that
you know story said earlier about my
grandfather passing happened
that i started thinking about it from
that perspective and like okay this
could actually be really interesting
um you know just feeling something
that's like you know drinks to numb the
pain
it's done with their life but isn't you
know can't die
um and then on the the female side of it
um it almost sounds terrible i'm
bringing up family as inspirations for
my vampire movie
they're lovely people but
my mother had said to me years ago when
she was growing up she was you know
in the 60s being raised to be like you
know good housewife
if she had aspirations it was to be a
teacher or a secretary
and then you know late 60s uh
women's rights and really started to
flourish
and she's like when i went off to
college all of a sudden being told i can
be
anything i want to be and like i never
thought of that before who
i don't even know who i want to be and
she's a i could go on forever she's an
amazingly talented and
smart woman who just it took really
until later on in life before she found
the things he's really passionate about
um and by that time it was like well
i can't really make this my career i'm
in my you know
late 50s or 60s so um
it was kind of the idea of like
exploring that a woman who's from that
type of
whether culture or an era where they
were really a
commodity that if they wanted to be
something it was to be a housewife and
a kind of a servant class
how does someone like that navigate and
find her own agency
in this current climate where women are
finally allowed to have a voice finally
allowed to
make those decisions that can guide
their life and
whether those decisions are right or
wrong i mean the character in the script
makes some dumb decisions um some
decisions that she regrets
uh but she had the the
agency and the freedom to make those
choices
and that's part of her coming
of her own you know into her own and
coming out of this uh this sort of
uh place where she'd been under yuri or
been a
you know villager and being able to kind
of find that
navigate that but then also learning
from the examples around her you know
her
her colleague and friend is another you
know cocktail waitress who maybe isn't
the best
example of how to you know make the
right decisions in your life and so
kind of explores that idea and
gabriella who plays daria was just such
a
perfect discovery for somebody to really
encapsulate that persona
authentically she was excellent is she
eastern european because she had a
beautiful accent but
i looked at her bio it didn't say yeah
she's actually hungarian
uh she grew up in hungary and she's been
in the u.s for a while now but uh
it was actually coincidentally i didn't
know this until after i'd cast her i was
talking about some of the inspirations
for when i was writing the family i
based it loosely off the uh
elizabeth bathory and her family uh
she's like infamous uh
often believed to have been a real
vampire and
found out that gabriella actually grew
up about
approximately 10 miles from their castle
so
probably you know sure ancestors of hers
had been
uh you know sacrifices to the bathrooms
back in the day
so or at least had known them so it's uh
i think she
she brought a lot of that heritage that
a really authentic heritage
to the character um
and also you know coming from a country
that politically and socially is very
different than ours
um you know something i always thought
about with my grandmother who was uh
she was also from eastern europe and
even you know
all these all those years later still
like a very reserved woman a very
thoughtful strong woman but very
reserved
in her ways like almost i mean
almost that old idea of knowing a
woman's place like she was
very much of that you know for
someone coming from a different culture
where that is still a thing
um that a woman has a place
having that in this character having
that be something that she's
actively trying to grow beyond but still
struggling with that
you know i think gabby's had this
naturalness with that because
she's coming from a place that kind of
still has some of those old world
social structures and philosophies
yeah i thought she played the part
extremely well and you'd also see it in
her eyes
she'd be processing something but
wouldn't necessarily say it
so you could tell okay she'll play the
role but
she's got another trick up her sleeve
and and yeah i like that too i thought
that was really well done that was a
huge
challenge for her and something i knew
early on was going to be
a difficult thing for anyone that played
that roles throughout the entire film
there's only two scenes where you see
her authentic
self or three scenes i should say uh
where you see her authentic self
for most of the movie her overt
emotions are a cover for what the
character is actually feeling
and so she really had to play that well
and
um a few of the people have seen it the
film more than once have said it's
interesting to watch it that second time
where you can
really see how she does you know
ride that line of like showing acting
the emotions that her character is
supposed to be acting but also showing
what the character is really feeling and
like you said so much of it is through
just her incredibly subtle mannerisms
her eyes
um just very gifted actress absolutely
and i i noticed she
she should have more credits i hope she
gets more work i looked at her imdb
and i really hope she gets more roles
because she's so talented we're actually
nervous about that with both her
and uh vanya for leads in a film
uh nika who was so helpful in the film
as well is a supporting role
uh she and i had some talks about that
in terms like are we really entrusting
in this film to
some actors that don't have a lot of
credits i mean bonnie had the theater
background at least
but you'd watch the tapes and he's like
i just i believed them so much
and uh you know really
glad i took that
you know had that faith in them and they
had the faith in me to
you know go off to vegas for a month
into this crazy
shoot um but yeah i got really fortunate
with them they're both
uh just phenomenal talents and i too
really hope to see them a lot more
i was joking i hope by the time we do
the sequel to this i can't afford them
we have a quote here from your executive
producer and distributor michael madison
and he's of indie rights and he put jeff
ryan
proved that he could deliver the highest
quality production value and dramatic
flair
on a budget that makes profitability
much more attainable than more directors
can deliver
so your first your first feature frey
reached what the top 15 in amazon war
films
yeah yeah warren military yeah frey
reached uh
it reached the top 15 war and military
films in amazon the u.s and it got to
number two
under art house independent films in the
uk
um they apparently don't have uh warren
military section so they put it under in
the art house
but uh it was wild i mean i just never
expected that i mean
we were literally right below i have a
screenshot of it we were right below
apocalypse now like if we if i go above
apocalypse now on amazon i'm just going
to retire i'm never going to top that
just go out while you're ahead um it was
wild i mean to see
our little film up do performing better
than you know
on amazon performing better than uh hurt
locker performing better than
you know platoon these films that were
just to me iconic
uh and great films uh
in in their own right uh and i mean
the uk one also have screen grabbed
because it was just surreal to see it
was literally the only film above it was
reservoir dogs
uh wow which is just wild to see uh
so yeah and again i mean we did that
film for so
little um there's a lot of expenses to
the film that add up i mean the festival
circuit marketing promotion
sound mastery and i spent a fortune on
on fray i was also
a director sound man and
i'm not a great sound man so a lot of
post budget on uh
refining the sound quality and stuff
like that
um but uh but yeah it was
great to see that happen and so you know
linda and michael
not only because of that but they've
seen what i've done with the commercial
world they've seen
you know just the diversity of projects
i can do that have been
successful for clients so they know that
even though frey is my only
was my only feature at the time that
i at least had the consistency be able
to deliver at a high
production value for modest budgets
and so and again i'm just i'm fortunate
the fact that i fell into the world of
doing
like you know fashion web commercials
and stuff where
you know i wouldn't have the greatest
budget for my end of it
but would make it work and
just got to constantly be shooting i
mean they have a new season every three
months so there'll be a new ad every
three months
and i was really fortunate constantly
refining that skill set
and then not having budgets always
having to get my own costumes do my own
set
design but
learning from these commercial shoots
from working with these you know
professional production designers
professional costume designers and all
sorts of stuff and so i
developed taste level for what you can
accomplish
with a budget but then also um
try to apply that to my own productions
where
you know and i i enjoy that stuff i
think that's part of having that fine
arts background helps
where it's not about the medium it's
about
the overall message in the writing and
development process
what kinds of questions were you asking
yourself about
the story about the characters um in
my writing process i actually i have a
weird process i've
read this book uh called the mind of the
maker by dorothy l
sayers and it's a fascinating book i
recommend to anybody in the creative
field she wrote in 19 1941 it came out
and she was a mystery writer but she
wrote this one it was about she's trying
to write a book of theology but
in trying to explain the mind of of a
god
she uses artists and writers as an
example
and it's a one of the things i loved
about it is she said that as a creator
you create the world you create the
physics of it and the laws of it and you
create the people that inhabit it
but then you give them free will and
to me that is the most organic form of
writing and so
my writing process is i try to i try to
just see the world and try to understand
it and know who my characters are and
the premise
and then i literally just i ferment on
that for a while until i feel like i
would understand i'll write notes and
stuff like that
and then i literally just sit down and
write
and just when it comes to a plot point
like what would they do here what would
they do here
and letting the character i've conjured
my mind have that free will to make
those choices instead of me guiding them
the only time i feel like i hit a
writer's block now
is when i'm trying to force them to do
something they wouldn't do
and so that is kind of my writing
process and then once i have a first
draft
out that's when i then go back and start
asking myself
those questions like okay here's some of
the themes i wanted to address
that maybe aren't as clear or in it how
do i put that into it how do i
is there a way place where this works is
there a place where this works
and so i have a kind of a weird writing
style i developed after reading that
book
and it was to me was a lifesaver because
that's why fray ended up being the film
it is was
i completely after reading that i
changed my whole creative
style and writing style based on what
i'd read in there
and it obviously worked with frey
so i decided to keep doing it that way
and
you know i think that's part of why
blood from stone is so different
as well is i don't set up a structure i
don't set up markers i don't have any
plot points i write down
it's like here's the world here's the
characters let's see where we go
and i actually like the process now
i can like fray i wrote in about three
weeks beginning to end
and the first draft of the final draft
there's a lot of editing a lot of
refining but as a whole they're very
similar
and same with blood from stone uh if you
look at the first draft in the final
draft other than
chopping a lot of pages off of it it's a
very similar story
uh so for better for worse the writing
style that works for me we'll see what
audiences feel but i enjoy it i
comes out much more organically i don't
get writer's block
it just takes a lot longer to write that
first page because you're trying to
figure out
all the aspects of the world that
they're in all the people
that are there but once you have that
all
just kind of let them loose in your
brain and see what happens
that's how i do it at least how did you
find that book or how did the book find
you it sounds like that sounds like a
very magical book i haven't actually
heard of it
it's yeah i found it i one of my
obsessions
is i collect old books
uh not like collectible old books i only
have a few of those
um but just i love going into antique
stores thrift stores old bookstores
and digging through for just ones that
sound interesting and
i'm obsessed with reading about
psychology i'm obsessed with reading
about religion and theology
i'm obsessed with reading about other
cultures um
and uh anthropology and all that sort of
stuff and i just
i was going through one of those
sections there was a book called the
mind of the maker i'm like
well that sounds fascinating and i read
just the first two pages of
her of dorothy's uh introduction
and i was laughing like it is hilarious
she the first two pages of it are just
brilliant it goes on i mean throughout
it she's actually funny she has an
entire chapter
i really feel like it was devoted to
just trashy and another author she hated
every time she is using examples of
creative blasphemy
she references his work and just trashes
him
she's absolutely hilarious in the book
it's a really thoughtful book a really
heavy book it's also a motivating one
because she wrote it during world war
ii and twice in the book she briefly
references
getting back to writing after a bombing
raid
and i think back to that whenever i've
had a bad day and i just don't feel like
being creative
i'm like she wrote one of my favorite
books while being bombed by nazis
i can get over my bad day and write
so it's just all around i highly
recommend that book if you can track it
down
i could also see inside of you that
maybe if you don't have a chance to be
creative
that could also drive you you know very
that you need to create i get that sense
that you need to always be
creating something not just in client
work but for yourself
yeah definitely always have to be
creating um
i said uh uh
i always say that i've been saying for a
long time that my career wasn't a
um you know being a filmmaker wasn't a
career choice the way of coping with my
own uh
mental health issues uh and
it really is i mean whether it was as a
little kid drawing on the walls to
get into animation constantly writing
little stories
it was just always a really a big part
of who i was
you know friends that would play like
dungeons and dragons instead of
playing those games i would be drawing
their stories and making picture books
of them
or that type of thing and just always
in that that realm of thinking so it is
a very natural part of just
life and i've had jobs where i couldn't
be creative and then i would get home in
the evenings and
i mean jared and i were roommates who
were broke we couldn't afford anything
but i had some acrylic paints and we had
a couple cereal boxes we started
painting cereal boxes
and uh we by the time we left our
apartment we had over 60 cereal boxes on
the walks we couldn't afford canvases
but we painted cereal boxes
um things like that that uh
just it is it's something you have to do
and
the beauty of it is when i was in high
school that short film i did
uh i had a magical moment i got a letter
you know this is before emails i got a
letter from somebody who had seen the
film
and she wrote to me the film was about
censorship
and she wrote to me about how it
impacted her thoughts on it and changed
her way of
of seeing this the uh the debate over
censorship that was going on
around that era of around the era of
natural-born killers and true romance
and
gangster rap and all that stuff they
were trying to ban um
and as uh you know 17 year old me
getting this letter from somebody
realizing that my movie had changed
their mind about something that
core to our values as a as a people
um i was like well what else could i
ever
want to do with my life um and you know
it took me 17 years to make fray and for
that to come out and then to be able to
get
letters from people have seen it to see
tears in people's eyes afterwards
about talking about how it made them
feel better about themselves or
understand their family member better
um yeah it's just to me
you know if i wasn't doing
the creative part is great i love that
and i would always do that but then to
be able to use it
to try and put some kind of good into
the world
uh which there's not a lot of so it's
like put some good into the world
make people feel like they understand
each other better make people feel like
we're
in this together um and
like what else could you ever hope to
accomplish as a
um so to me that's what motivates me to
keep going and
keep doing my own films because you know
if somebody else is pain i might not be
able to get away with some of the themes
i deal with and that type of thing
if you're answering to somebody you tend
to self-censor
and by the way i i should have rephrased
i didn't mean that you would go crazy
not doing art but that it seems like
that would be
something more in your wheelhouse than
going to the mall oh yeah
oh totally that's how i should have
probably phrased it but i appreciate how
you
how you added that yeah yeah no i mean
i i call my apartment my cave because
it's i don't
i don't like to leave it and um yeah i'm
just much happier when i'm just
making stuff or at least at the very
least honestly just sitting back and
contemplating reading about other
reading other people's books um you know
reading about other lives other ideas
reading about philosophy or
all that sort of stuff like i'd rather
be in that world trying to understand
the world
than being a part of the world being a
part of the world
is not my favorite thing trying to
understand it i love doing
that makes sense especially now yeah
what are some big revelations you've had
or the biggest success you've had when
developing this story
about blood from stone the big success i
mean the film hasn't come out yet so i'm
really curious to see how people
interpret it because again it's uh
it's a weird film it's not a weird film
in like the most
uh overt way it's not something like
you know like the lighthouse which is
such a
beautiful brilliant film it's also very
obviously like you
you know going to that it's a different
movie um this one is a little bit more
subtle and how it's weird so i'm curious
how people are going to respond to it
but
for me personally i don't know about
like a
revelatory but the thing i'm the
proudest of
on a very personal level it was the
first
feature i've ever i've been the
cinematographer on
um as well and it had a very complicated
visual language addisola who's here with
me he and i
really sat down like shot listed and
storyboarded this whole thing
um because every shot in it
or every scene really is like they're
they overlap and they weave and
a lot of the visual dynamics of it um
communicate between scenes something you
know the way a shot is composed in one
scene speaks to how something's composed
in another
what you're seeing in one storyline is
complemented or contrasted in another
storyline and the way they story lines
in our weave
if i butchered some shots if they didn't
turn in
if i didn't get them the way that i'd
intended uh
the film would have completely fallen
apart at the seams uh
so much of the juxtaposition between the
the interwoven storylines really is what
makes
some of the dramatic aspects of the film
work
and even some of the themes really work
uh
and so when we got a final edit of it
and i was watching it back i'm like this
is
absolute insanity and i can't believe it
worked
um you know there's almost no
establishing shots in the whole movie
there's i think
five establishing shots in the whole
film maybe four
um you know we closed down
main street in las vegas and had cop
cars and all sorts of stuff and the
entire thing is done
other than two shots the entire thing's
done on a very tight lens
where you only are focused on the one
character even though there's all this
chaos going on around him
um just things like that that visually
were
um against the grain like not how i
would
how not how you're supposed to shoot a
scene not how you're supposed to
you know cover it and dissect it and all
that
and just believing that what i was
seeing in my head was actually going to
work
um and then coming out on the other side
and like oh
it actually did you know is it the most
cinematically masterful film ever made
no
um but as a visual language to do
something so off kilter and actually
have it succeed i'm
quite excited about how did you go about
developing these vampire characters
i've kind of have parts of myself in all
of them
uh like you know vania of the year
you know his performance as europe he
brought to a whole other level
but there's that part of me that's just
impulsive
and very much about like just
living in the moment um doing things you
regret
not understanding why you know you have
you're perceived a certain way all that
sort of stuff
um darya's character again deal with a
lot of that
deal with you know kind of my own like
self-repression
uh as well so it's a lot like in a way
there's so much of me and all the
characters
uh and that's
i think that's just essential it's like
there's a
line that's told to every writer and
it's a dangerous one where they say
write what you know and too
often times i find that makes writers
kind of go with most
obvious like well i await tables so my
character is going to be a waiter who
wants to be a filmmaker
it's like no not necessarily that but
put what you know into your characters
like create something fantastical if you
want
but put yourself into those characters
put people that you know
into those characters so that way when
you're writing them they feel authentic
they feel real
um especially for for myself like who
who needs to see another movie about
some
average white guy who wants to get the
girl and
you know ends up succeeding in the end
or not or whatever it's like
that story's been told a hundred times i
don't even want to watch a movie about
my life
so in terms of that like being able to
find something interesting about the
life i've had about my own persona and
put that into my characters
and then you know then from there just
have fun with it okay here's my
character
now set them free what are they gonna do
once they're out in the world
um you know what's yuri gonna do when
he's in a
he's in a in an uber ride chair and
some drunk people get in next to him and
they're obnoxious
me i would be quiet and ignore them
his character he's a beast and he's a
vampire so he kills them
um then he feels bad for the driver
who's now stuck in the situation
and now how does he handle that well you
know and so
just kind of for me it's like i like to
create the characters put them in a
scenario and see where they go
what are your thoughts on writing a
protagonist that's a villain
uh i mean i really feel like any
protagonist if they're
authentic is also going to be a villain
everybody's got that side to him
and i hopefully i'm not just projecting
myself out there by saying that uh
but um to me it's not a
i don't i don't even like the idea of
having villains
having like protagonist antagonists
because
it's really it's all about perspective
you know you flip the lens around
and you know the bad guy is actually
he's doing what he feels is the right
thing to do in his mind he's justified
it's why
you know you go back in history you look
at nazi propaganda films
they didn't shoot them intending hitler
to look like the villain
but us looking back at it now it's very
iconic
villain imagery you see it in the new
star wars films you see in so many
movies they take that imagery
and they flip it around that was
obviously not the intent
of those films and so any character if
you
write a really fleshed out character i
mean
even on i mean the nazi thing is a big
scale on a personal scale we've all been
in relationships
you had a fight with your significant
other you know you're right
until a certain part of the argument
where you're like oh no you just made a
really good point no
okay i'm in the wrong on that so even in
that argument like you went into it
you were the hero and then you ended
with like oh no i'm the villain
uh so that's how i approach my
characters
is not thinking who's the good guy who's
the bad guy
who's the you know who's the one i'm
rooting for
in the end it's just let's get to know
them let's see who they are
and let the audience decide who they
think is like one of my favorite things
and i don't want to spoil too much for
those who haven't seen it but one of my
favorite things is
daria's character she starts out she's
very much the damsel in distress type of
trope she's
you know the ex-girlfriend escaped an
abusive relationship
she's with the sky that we've all seen
him be a monster
and then the story makes a turn and you
start realizing
she's not as helpless as i thought she
was how much of a victim is she really
and then you see that she's even
reconciling that of who she wants to be
versus who she is
and to me that's so much more
interesting than being oh she's good and
he's bad
uh i just i feel like that's where so
many movies become
so cookie cutter and so boring is when
it's so obvious
who who's who in the film
by i want it to be by the end of the
film you're still trying to figure out
wait who was i supposed to be rooting
for like i'm happy how i ended but why
am i happy they were terrible
or um you know kind of wanting to know
more like if
i feel like if a movie ends and you're
you're trying to peace out
in your mind where this character went
and what they did and you're still
thinking about
the decisions they made then that's
that's a successful film because it
makes you feel like that world was real
and you cared about those characters you
found them interesting enough to
contemplate how was it writing two
female characters
one of them actually had very masculine
qualities to her though
yeah in the typical stereotype she was
very strong
and was actually lifting him up well
she's the older sister and i have a very
strong older sister
she was always the boss growing up and
even to this day we still kind of have
that fun uh
you know we have fun with it now but
still have that and so writing the older
sister role in the film was easy because
um you know and honestly like there's a
lot of strong women in my family lineage
even
going back i mean uh an aunt on my
mother's side was a postal carrier in
alaska
back when she had to get around on a dog
sled
in the early 1900's oh wow long lineage
of strong women um
you know great-grandmother raised her
kids as a single mother during the great
depression
my grandmother on my mom's side was uh
you know
a working woman in the 50s and stuff
like that um and so
just strong women to me that's like
that's just
how they should be written um
and uh and then just in my life i've
i've
been one of those guys that's always had
a circle of
female friends i actually enjoy them as
human beings
and as equals and so knowing know
them on that personal level and not just
seeing them as relationship or conquest
and so to me that it uh
even when i'm writing them there's
obviously gender differences in terms of
how they're
the the specific experiences that they
have throughout the film there's going
to be that but
i don't approach it like writing oh this
is a woman character to me i'm just
writing
a character that happens to be a woman
my
favorite author of all time janette
winterson she
she once in an interview was asked how
it feels to be
such a well-respected lesbian author
and she retorted back she's like i'm not
a lesbian author i'm an
author who happens to like women
i feel like from the writing perspective
that's how i should treat my characters
is yes
we all have aspects of our gender and
race and all that that does
affect our our uh specifics
uh in life in a lot of ways but in the
end
i at least i want to believe that we're
all human beings and
uh should when i write them i write
different characters
in that way with an awareness
of you know whatever differences that
they may have
from myself but not trying to make that
their defining character trait
does that make sense it does did you
like a lot of female characters in film
noir
oh yeah because they were quite strong
and at times conniving and clever
definitely i mean definitely in classic
films it was interesting because
you know we think that era we think very
defined gender roles
but uh in classic films and he had
catherine hepburn and bringing up baby
is one of my
favorite performances of all time she's
just phenomenal in that in a powerhouse
uh you know so there's so many great
ones out there
angela bassett was one of my big
favorites in strange days when i saw her
in that and just
how incredible she was than that when i
was you know i was in the 90s but just
such a phenomenal performance
you have just so many strong great
performances by female actresses you
know we were mentioning
julia lewis earlier uh
yeah i just think being able to bring
that into a film
you know there's a lot of talk about
that right now in terms like social
justice and all that
it's always been there it's just been as
it's not been as common as it should be
um but i don't think it's doing anything
new it's not
it's not changing anything it's just you
know
to a certain extent maybe just a
reflection of uh of our current
selves or you know others people that
created it like for myself
obviously i said strong women are a
natural part of my life i'm gonna have
that in my stories
um
others just haven't had that in you know
maybe that's why you don't see it as
much in other films
but it's not like an active choice i
make it's just how they come out
what does story structure mean to you
story structure for me
is uh it's essential
and yet at the same time i i try to
ignore it
if that makes sense it's i mean you know
with all the stuff i've
talked a bit about kind of like going to
defy conventions or whatever
but i also do believe that as an artist
if you don't understand what those
conventions are
what the structures are then you're not
defining them you just don't know what
you're doing
if you don't follow them and so i really
did spend
you know read about it a lot and i've
you know studied in terms like story
structure and the
you know the three act the fire back
structure all that type of stuff
there's such a value to it i mean even
if it's not
obvious that it's there in a lot of
films it should
kind of be there and so i do follow that
like this one i feel like has like the
traditional
five act structure just in a very loose
way
um and
it's just you know if you don't hit
certain plot points by certain points
you're gonna
bore your audience uh you know it's one
thing to challenge an audience and to
ask them to really commit themselves to
your story it's another to
you know force them to you know wait
forever for something to happen or to
not give them something to cling on to
narratively
so i do try to keep the audience's
interest and attention at my in their in
my mind when i'm
maybe not the first draft but as i'm
editing and refining the script i like
to keep that audience uh
perspective in mind like okay they have
to watch this so let me think about them
now
uh and so that's where i think knowing
structure really comes into play is just
knowing
the best way to reach those beats hit
those moments
uh i did say earlier though i'm not a
big fan of character arcs at least not
obvious ones because i feel like in real
life
unless something traumatic happens to
you you don't actually
change you just adjust or um
so for me instead of worrying about a
character arc like well he starts here
and he ends
this person or he finds this out of
himself and changes here
i kind of like to create a personality
type
and a psychology and then put them into
a situation like okay now how do they
cope with this
what is that's kind of more how we are
in real life is
you know i am who i am if you put me in
a burning building i'm not going to
suddenly turn into a hero i'm probably
going to flee
um you know what circumstances
would it take for me to become that hero
um
it would have to be for a loved one uh
my cats depending on the day maybe i
would risk it
uh but you know that's to me is the
interesting thing is
not necessarily like hitting the ark in
the traditional way but setting those
plot points of like okay at this point
this character has this happened to him
and
he does this and then at this point he
realizes oh
this all backfired and then it you know
so that's kind of how i like to follow
the structure like you have those points
but
in terms like so much of the traditional
writing on story structure and
everything i'm not a fan of a lot of the
guidance
on how his stories should develop
you know obviously there's some very
very successful filmmakers that have
followed those formulas and done quite
well with it
so you know take my my opinion on it for
what it's worth
um on my second film we'll see how it do
how it does
so but that's at least how i approach it
personally
how long did you work on the screenplay
it's debatable i mean
i literally had my first notes written
down when i was in high school so a few
decades
um uh it went through various different
forms
and then i would get discouraged because
again what am i bringing to the vampire
genre that's worth the damn
um and then
uh when i really when the when it
clicked for me like oh this is a story i
want to tell
i started fermenting on it right a
little bit here and there and after
about
four months of just kind of letting it
still in my brain and writing some notes
here and there and some thoughts and
another thing i do is because i read a
lot i have a little black book
of quotes that i keep of just lines i'm
like this
because so many authors can say
something in one throwaway line that
would take me an entire essay to
express so i like to write those down
and just keep those and so i kind of
like picked my quotes that
capture the essence the story i want to
tell then sat down and wrote it in the
first draft
i literally had it in three weeks and
then i sent it to
no actually i revised that one i sent
the second draft to a few friends
get some feedback some notes um
and then reworked it over the course of
about six months and then started up on
production
so when you were in high school where
were you writing were like was this
during like
class break or something and you're like
writing on a composite you know like
tear out sheet yeah during class
sometimes i was not the best student
the fact i made through high school was
only thanks to the graciousness of some
teachers who believed i had potential
if i just learned how to put the work in
i'm still grateful for them because that
really is what it comes down to is it
doesn't matter how talented you are if
you don't put the work in nobody's going
to see your talent
so getting those f's in high school was
a valuable learning experience
um but yeah i was i would draw and
write during class after class i'd go
home and
had a cave then that i made and i would
be in my little cave drawing and writing
and just constantly coming up with ideas
most of them looking back garbage i was
not a prodigy i was definitely
still developing a voice but yeah i just
loved it i absolutely loved
just creating little worlds or stories
or ideas and imagining them
uh and even to this day i mean that's
you'll half time you'll find me on my
patio with a book in hand
reading something or just contemplating
ideas themes whatever
it's kind of my favorite way to pass the
time
what tv shows did you watch when you
were in high school
oh i have terrible taste in tv
uh let's see what would be
in high school actually oddly enough in
high school i wasn't watching a lot of
tv i watched more movies then but
i was obsessed with animation i'm still
an animation junkie i watched south park
religiously um
but back then i mean i was watching
again some older was like
animaniacs i was watching every
afternoon after school
loved that show still one of the
all-time greats
so i was watching that watching old
still obsessed but definitely back then
i was obsessed with the old
uh warner brothers and hannah barbera
cartoons from tom and jerry
to bugs bunny and all that stuff loved
all those classics tech savory cartoons
which uh problematic by today's
standards but
i loved them back then uh you know
yeah i was a true animation junkie for
and then i've always been a news junkie
too i watched the news almost every
night
um you know during my high school years
were uh
some pretty you know for me defining
moments in
uh kind of the way i saw our society and
our
you know authority and stuff like that
with
um you know we had the uh the branch
davidians in waco when i was
you know just entering my teens and you
had
the columbine shootings and you know i
mean i had made some
films up at that point in my in my high
school with friends where there were
guns involved in stuff like that in the
in you know
fake guns but i was doing that and then
the columbine thing happened and just
everything changed
um and so
uh yeah but that to me was uh
what i watched i would go between
cartoons and then the serious stuff
i'm still kind of that way like i've
seen all the fast and furious films
and then i'll go watch some art house
and then i'll read the news
so what screenwriting mistakes have you
made in your earlier work
that you've corrected oh so many
mistakes in my early work uh the biggest
one
and it still survives in a short film
that i made uh
was monologues oh my god i used to write
some obscenely long pretentious
monologues
as you can probably tell i've very
opinionated about things
you know kind of philosophical about
things
and i would put way too much that into
my characters
and it was annoying and i feel bad for
the actors i had to try and deliver
those things
um that was the big one learning to
you know the obvious thing show not tell
that was hard for me it really took
trusting my own abilities as a filmmaker
trusting the audience as another big
part of it you know
we've all got this idea that because
fast nefarious is so popular because
kind of
derivative films are so popular that
audiences aren't smart
they are smart just sometimes they want
to turn their brain off but if you're
making a film that allow
that encourages them to turn their brain
on they'll go just as deep as you want
them to go
and so that to me was a big part of it
is
learning to write better for sure
learning to write smarter
but then also trusting that i don't have
to explain everything to the audience
that they can figure it out
and that just that took time and
experience you know going to festivals
and seeing how
audiences responded to my films seeing
how they responded other films and just
you know learning to trust both myself
and audiences was the biggest
change for me and not being so
on the nose about my writing
has overriding ever been an issue for
you i know you talked about
you had these characters with these
monologues and their opinions and things
but in terms of the actual story
has overriding ever been an issue for
you um i haven't done that much
overwriting
uh blood from stone i've definitely
chopped
a good chunk of it off i mean i already
knew the film that i had in my mind was
not going to be a 90 minute film it was
going to be
i was assuming at least 145 150
maybe even 155 the fact it's over two
hours
uh my distributors weren't happy about
that but
upon seeing it they're like it works
it's tight it's a tight
two hour and four minute movie but um
even with that the script itself did
have some and it was really that it's
still
my natural go too is i'm going to write
it down and then
so i had a lot of dialogue that was way
too long you know
i'm sure you noticed there's the scene
of the brother and sister in the bar
talking
that goes on for a little while i love
it a few people love it some say it's
too long
i left it in um i think the actors did
great with it so i
i enjoyed on that level um
but yeah i do find myself doing that and
i often times my first draft and my
second draft
maybe first a third draft there's at
least a ten page difference of how much
i've cut out
uh frey was the only one that wasn't
that way
frey was just a very short succinct
script
the actual script for that is just over
60 pages
um it was a very short succinct one
so and was a lot of the dialogue
improv no it was just that film has so
many scenes
of i mean there's only so many ways you
can write he looks off in the distance
depressed
and you know but when you're shooting it
and you have brian's phenomenal
performance with jaron's amazing
cinematography
that one line is a minute or two minutes
of the film
and it's an incredibly powerful minute
or two minutes because
of the visuals and the performance in it
but because i wasn't trying to sell the
script i wasn't trying to impress
anybody with the script it was literally
going to be
read by our team i didn't embellish with
a bunch of descriptions or anything like
that i was just like
you know the character's name is justin
like justin walks to
uh you know the job interview he you
know then i write the job interview
dialogue and then
he walks home i wouldn't you know
embellish and all that
because i had it in my head i knew jaren
was going to make it look great i knew
brian was going to kill it as a
performer
so wrote a really lazy script for that
one
probably not the best thing to say to
inspire people to get really good at
being professional writers
but because like i said i wasn't trying
to sell it i wasn't trying to impress
anybody with it
i just wrote it for me and my little
crew
so that's why that one i got away with
being lazy
i think that's it kind of says a lot in
that that you weren't really writing for
the market
yeah you weren't writing to impress
whomever
it was just a story that you really want
to tell you had a family member that
experienced this
you'd met people and that's where a lot
of that came from
it was wild too because uh when it came
out and we got the good reviews of that
i got an email one day from the academy
of motion pictures of
arts and sciences and they requested a
copy of the script for their permanent
library
which was amazing and
i was like i'm kind of embarrassed to
say give them this script it's like
you know let me at least create a proper
title page for it
um and uh yeah so it was kind of wild
that like probably my laziest script so
far has been my most successful
so i don't know what that says about me
as a writer
maybe i just shouldn't try so hard
or that's just the story that you're
writing and how connected you
i think that's a big part of it is
really like the story and that one just
there was so much of my own
you know i told you about the research i
did getting to know so many
people who were living that life my own
cousin's experiences
it kind of just that one just flowed out
and i had a very specific idea for it
so um i think that's kind of key in
writing is
you know really know what you're writing
have a
have a like really believe it and just
trust it as you're writing it
how do you work with actors i have a
great time working with actors and
pretty much all the actors i've worked
with still like me so that's a good sign
i when i'm working with actors i really
try to focus on
the early stages one is just getting
them to feel comfortable with
me because they're putting a lot of
faith in me as a director
uh that i'm going to steer them in the
right direction
that i know what i'm talking about uh
you know every actor especially you know
um people are starting out or
that do a lot of supporting work so many
of them get thrown into these just
terrible movies where they're almost
ashamed they were part of it
um and so they're putting a lot of faith
in me as a director and as a writer that
you know
that i'm going to deliver for them and
so kind of get them comfortable let them
know kind of my vision who i see their
character as what i see it saying
all that but then i work with them to
feel really comfortable
with their understanding of the
character even before we get into lines
um really talking with them who did they
see their character as
what is you know when the character does
this in a scene do you have any
questions about that or is there any
questions you have about your character
um i really want them to feel like they
know that
person and that therefore when they're
playing them they're not they're not
thinking about
notes they had there's nothing worse i
mean
there's a lot of actors process and each
of them has their own process someone
write a very complicated chart
that tracks their character's arc and
their choices throughout the whole film
which is great because you want you know
if that's how they do it you want them
to feel like they know their character
and they understand it they can see the
whole thing
but the last thing you want to see is
when they're performing you don't want
to see them thinking about those notes
you want them to be living in the moment
and so
getting to the point where they trust
they know the character
that's when i know i have i have a good
performance once we get to that stage i
start feeling really good about it
you know when we're doing fray brian uh
we walked worked on his walk for days
getting his walk down to where you could
see that he had the physical wound but
you can also see he was trying to hide
it
um him spending that time with those uh
those veterans was a huge breakthrough
for him it changed his
his own personal perspective on it he
actually said to me after that he said
because i was really excited about this
movie because it's an incredible role
and i
you know really feel like it's a great
opportunity for me as an actor
but after meeting these guys he's like i
all i can think about now is i just hope
i can do their story justice
and that to me was when it changed it
became for him it wasn't about
playing a role it became real to him uh
he
saw the lives that those guys had and
obviously i couldn't do that with the
vampire film
but part of it with them was you know
the casting vania's from serbia
gabby's from hungary uh
and so they come from the worlds of
these vampires are from
they had that folklore and stuff growing
up so i was a big part of it already
naturally their accent is there
so we have to come up with some cheesy
dracula accent
but then helping them understand and
find those connections that they have to
them personally
and then from there creating onset an
environment where they
feel safe to take risks
to not feel like if they flub a line
that i'm going to
be upset with them and
for vania part of it he's an amazing
talent but english isn't his first
language
uh you know he struggled with some of my
dialogues to let allow him the freedom
to make it his own and some of his
improv in it and some of the lines he
came up with was so much better than
what i wrote
uh he has some throwaway lines that i up
that still make me laugh and i've seen
the film a thousand times now
uh so allowing them to really
personalize it and make it themselves
and not feeling like as the writer
director that i'm losing my vision
because they're taking something in a
new way
it's almost like okay let's go for this
ride let's see where they take me now
uh and i just find like that just helps
it's again it's empowering to them
keeps them from feeling like they're
walking on eggshells that you know
worrying about making a mistake
um but then also not being afraid to
correct them if something's really
you know the choice isn't right having
that conversation
catching them early on it feeling like
you know again if you have that trust
they're going to respect when i speak up
and i'm like no that's not how
how your character would go we can have
that discussion they can understand why
um had that with vania i had that with
gabby had that with brian have had that
with all my actors where you have that
moment where it's like
you know it's great i like what you were
trying to do there but
let's think about it from this
perspective of why your character
wouldn't do that
and i always say if i can't justify a
choice it's not the right choice
so with any actor i always have that
justification otherwise
let them do it their way if i'm going to
give them a note there's going to be a
reason for it otherwise i want them to
feel like
they've got it what are the pros and
cons of working with non-actors you know
when you see movies sometimes let's say
winners bone
where you're like you know what those
are real people it seems like for the
most part in the background
and it really lends to the film and just
from watching the trailer of fray
i think you had said that there were
non-actors in it but i i could
it really made me feel like i was there
in a town a small town logging area it's
for for any film i think it's it can be
great
if you want to if you want to have
authenticity just use the real people
uh it makes a world of difference
because
you know great character actors can
embody
interesting characters for sure
but there is still something different
from an
actor playing somebody like that versus
the real person that's their
life and that's what they do um
so authenticity is the greatest
attribute of it
um for a low-budget film you know
there's no way on a movie like that i
was able to cast
and afford uh 30 great extras
or with or you know supporting roles
stuff like that like
i can only bring on so many people and i
would rather have
somebody who's real and maybe not the
best actor
versus a bad actor who's not real
um you know if you threw like the uh
there's a scene where he's interviewing
for a job at a dairy queen
and becky was the actual manager of that
dairy queen
who just does the scene in the interview
now
she just had to be herself she was doing
an actual job interview it just happened
to be on camera
and she was nervous and everything but
we got her comfortable and she did it
and
and with non-actors i don't give them
dialogue i give them point a and point b
now just be you and then the actor you
know brian was great at impro
improv so he could go with it he could
roll with it he knew things he had to
get across so he would steer it that way
so that's part of having a very talented
actor to work with that can steer a
scene like that
with becky i was like okay you're
interviewing him he's got to have these
qualifications you've got to ask him
about this
and then just do a normal interview and
then trust also that you can pull it off
in editing and make it work
so that was a big thing and one of my
favorite moments from that was when
la weekly put out the review they ended
the review
quoting becky she actually had a line in
that
that when when she said it i was just
like that's better than anything i will
ever write
it was a question she asks him what do
you think qualifies you to work
this establishment and he resorts back
well you know i did five tours of duty
here but i don't see how that will help
me at it you know and
her response back as well it can be a
battlefield in here sometimes especially
during the summer
i'm just like i would have never thought
of that and that's the greatest answer
to that line
to that ever um and i love the fact that
this woman who's a manager at a dairy
queen in the coastal mountains of oregon
was literally quoted in la weekly
so that's that's the beauty of having a
non-actor is they can bring that level
of realness to
that's their daily life and so if you
just let them be themselves
but that's the hard part as a director
is you can't
you can't direct them you literally give
them
um the scenario and then just trust them
to be themselves
and then hopefully you get what you need
out of it
so you're also not getting a lot of
takes uh you do more than two or three
takes they start getting self-conscious
and then you've lost them you had a
300-plus page production bible
yes can you tell us
when you started assembling that and did
you leave anything out
see the production bible i'd never
compiled anything like this before
other than obviously editing a feature i
guess is a bigger task but
with this film because it was a very
modest budget
and uh and i guess because i
just wanted to drive myself insane i
decided not only was i
directing and shooting it
but i was also going to be doing the
production design
props costumes set dressing
all of that and so i knew if i didn't
have every detailed or written down
i would lose track first day into
shooting i would have no idea what shot
is next
i would if i just had a shot list i
wouldn't remember like well what was the
composition what was i even think why
was i
you know why did i want to just stay in
close-ups the whole time why didn't i
want to have
so i knew i needed to have it all laid
out so i had all the storyboards
i had all the every scene was broken
down by each shot
in each shot what props were needed what
costumes were needed which actors were
in it which were extras
vehicles the location everything broken
down
because i knew if i didn't have that you
know
i'd only done one feature before but i
knew in that one there were times where
jared and i would be looking at the
script in the shot list trying to
remember like wait how did that scene
end okay that scene ended in a close-up
so we can't start this one with a
close-up
and we're like no wait no no we ended it
with a wide shot so okay we do start
this one with
like trying to figure out the visual
language and i was
you know jaren for the longest time was
a crutch for me the guy's just
you know a master of visual storytelling
that i didn't really have to worry about
it much well you know
he's doing big movies now so i was like
well i guess i'll just shoot this one
myself
and uh um but yeah without having him as
a crutch i was really nervous going into
it
and then having so many different
responsibilities creatively on it
i had to and i'm so glad i did because
if i didn't have that production
bible this thing would have been a just
a flaming train wreck
so any advice to filmmakers on
how they should begin one maybe it won't
be 300 plus pages but
but but just a more condensed version i
mean definitely
have all those elements because if
you're if you're doing a lower budget
film you probably don't have somebody
who's a department head for all the
props
and adora ahead for costumes and all
that you probably have
if you're lucky of one person that's
overseeing that
sometimes it's just you know everybody's
taking turns on it and you've got actors
bringing their own wardrobe or whatever
but if you do that breakdown you think
about things like okay in this scene
these three guys get bitten by a vampire
so their shirts are going to get bloody
which means i am bringing their shirts
because i'm not paying for their laundry
bills
uh plus probably won't wash out so
knowing that type of stuff and then just
realizing um
you know when you're doing that when
you're doing that shot list you start
thinking about
little things that you wouldn't
necessarily think about like
um there's a scene in it where he throws
a cell phone out the window
it wasn't until i was going through
really like putting together this
production bible where i'm like
oh i need to bring a disposable phone i
need to bring a phone that's dead so or
that
nobody wants any more otherwise i guess
it'll be my phone we throw out the
window
so that sort of thing like you know uh
trying to reach out to friends like hey
anybody got an old cell phone they don't
need anymore
that still powers on stuff like that
like
i wouldn't have thought of that and so i
highly recommend
putting together not just a shot list
but really some level of production
bible where you know every day when you
walk on the set
you've already gone through a checklist
of the props that you need the costumes
you need
making sure you have the people that you
need and all sorts of stuff and granted
a lot of that's a producer
you know producer role other department
heads but we just
on this one it was really i mean michael
is an amazing producer and he
handled the logistics well but a lot of
the department heads were
me and other people just kind of putting
our heads together
and so we've got you know nika helping
as a production coordinator but she's
also acting in
you know quarter of the movie uh you've
got sarah as my aed and script
supervisor but she's also acting in part
of the movie
um as well as she's helping jeff black
with sound and she's helping with
getting you know helping michael arrange
food deliveries and all sorts of stuff
like we're all pulled in so many
different directions
the fact that we could all go back to
this production bible and see oh we got
this we've got this this is taken care
of this is checked off
it's a great feeling and there's nothing
like finishing the day and just seeing
everything on the page
checked off it's the greatest feeling in
the world like we got it all
we can go to sleep now so i highly
recommend it it's a lot of tedious work
to start with
but it's the most gratifying thing while
you're shooting because
just knowing you got everything and be
able to check it all off as you
accomplish it
it just gives you peace of mind
and are you just getting like a
three-ring binder yeah and then and then
putting in stuff in these like plastic
um exact separators yeah it is it's just
it's a three-ring binder
um i've got uh basically
each scene has a divider between it so
um when i'm making it that's the other
hard part is like so i made it just in
the order of the script
but then once michael and i had our
shooting schedule down
i reorganized it by day so it's like
okay well we're doing this this day so
that was the tricky part with this one
because
you know certain scenes just like in any
film you break them up this one's being
shot at that part of the day this was
being tried that part of the day we
hadn't
we had certain scenes that part of them
were shot in laughlin part was shot in
vegas and part was shot in la
um so breaking it up by day was also
essential because
be like okay on day you know once you
get to day 20
you know the script doesn't even mean
anything to you anymore it's all
abstract at that point it's
like you know your brain is just such a
jumbled mess
so you can look at okay on day 20 oh
good okay we're doing the apartment
scene so we don't have to deal with
crowds don't deal with the casino and
deal with that
but you know we've got to make sure we
have the blood bags we've got to make
sure that we have her running shoes and
we have to have this
and that so it just
it was it was essential for that and
then um
like i said just breaking it down by day
was essential too and
we just have a divider between each one
and then outside of course have the pdf
file and i would just
each day print out a couple copies for
everybody to have so that way
you know again checklist uh nika going
through costumes making sure
we had extras costumes and we had the
you know
that vania had the right shirt on that
day that matched with the other scenes
and stuff like that
so um yeah i highly recommend keep it as
organized as possible
as thorough as possible again it's
tedious it's a very tedious process i
spent
probably as much time playing the
production bible as i did the first
draft of the script
but it saved me so many times and he
helped
just kept it all organized i didn't have
to think like i could look
you see uh you know right here you've
got your uh shot
uh the storyboard with the shot
description underneath it
and you can see all the shots lined up
she's like oh that's why i decided to go
in for a close-up here
because it was described and it made
sense whereas if it just been storyboard
or
shot list it wouldn't have worked for me
now granted
that's if you have you know not
everybody needs storyboards we didn't do
it on fray
um partly because oftentimes i would
just defer to jaren on
visuals but you know not everybody needs
that but i feel like the more
information you have the better
because that's one thing i did find was
scary when i was doing fray is that
feeling of forgetting
even what you were doing it's like wait
where are we today
we've shot like four scenes and we're
going into five i don't remember what
this is in the script i remember what i
was trying to accomplish with it
um so yeah i just think it's essential
to have that
how do you plan a shoot where you know
there will be rain where
rain is an actual part of the scene
um i try not to write too much around
mother nature because
while she can be an amazing gaffer at
times she also can be very finicky
um and
in fact fray i'd initially written it i
mean we shot it in march in the coastal
mountains of oregon
thinking it was just going to be gloomy
gray and wet the whole time
and it was so sunny while we were
shooting we'd go to lunch
and the waitress would be like oh you're
so lucky it's never this nice in the
spring
i was like oh i wanted gloom i wanted
rain
um that being said when it does happen
i you know this is a budget thing when
it comes to
mother nature in terms of rain and the
elements
i always prefer artificial to the real
deal
um shooting in the real rain
is just it's hellish
um you know especially if you don't have
proper
you know if you don't have a huge budget
you have all the proper tents and the
proper housing for the camera and all
that sort of stuff
it's i mean the anxiety of like
oh i don't want to get the camera wet so
you've got your ac instead of pulling
focus he's got an umbrella over your
head
um you know all that type of stuff i try
to use
artificial rain and snow
or whatever when i can now granted
usually it's commercial projects that
have that budget it's not my own
uh but even you know shooting vegas the
best
in laughlin the best time we had was uh
was august in august in nevada
is not pleasant um
poor adushola was crammed to the back of
that prius for three nights of shooting
in the trunk monitoring audio and
and sound while i'm up in the passenger
seat shooting it
and we have no air conditioning on it's
100 you know for audio but you know 115
degrees
outside um so yeah
i personally try to avoid the elements
as much as possible because i just
like i could never do the revenant that
would i would uh
i'd probably give up about a weekend
um i know some filmmakers love that type
of stuff
i personally i prefer to i prefer
uh you know even if it's something as
simple as a garden hose for rain i'll
use that you know put your thumb over it
have it far enough away
get the rain use some post effects to
kind of gloom it up a little bit and add
some depth to it
um that's the joy of knowing how to do
some basic special effects as i know how
to i know how to fake a lot of that type
of stuff
and do it where it looks convincing
enough that people don't notice that
it's fake
what's your favorite scene in the movie
flood from stone
uh favorite scene it's a tough one
um i'm kind of it's
like my friend bobby who plays mike the
convention goer his death scene every
time i see it i text him and just tell
him how much i love watching him die
um he just i love that scene uh
you know gabby's performance in it is
just vicious
and so cold and just great
turning points i like that one but i
really think
my favorite one is uh is the
conversation with
nika and vanya's uh you know victoria
and yuri
just brother and sister just
you know shooting the having a
great time
with getting a little drunk and just
talking about the good old days
and their back and forth and their
dynamic it was a fun scene to write
it's obviously somewhat exposition heavy
they tried to make it fun and then just
their deliveries like they brought it to
life so well
that for me it's the first dialogue
scene i've ever written that i'm
actually really proud of
and a lot of it is really their their
delivery and the way that they're just
you know so great together on camera and
even though it's a long scene
i enjoy it every time i see it i just
love what they did with it
so that's my favorite yeah i think you
learn a lot about the characters and
their motivations from that scene i mean
i don't wanna i don't know if this is a
spoiler but
is it that and we may have to take this
out where she says like dad's gonna cut
you off if you don't clean up your act
yeah yeah and then you go oh now i see
this guy better okay now i get
some of who he is you know yeah like you
can see he's kind of like the black
sheep the rebellious one
the guy that you know never you know
especially for people are into vampire
lore you know for the first like half
the movie
like these are weird vampires and then
when nika's character arrives
you start to find out why they're so
different like she's
really a lot more of this typical
vampire
image and type of personality type
and then you start to see why the two
that you've been following are not like
the vampires that you would normally see
in a movie and
you know again try not to be too
exposition heavy or too
too heavy-handed trying to make it fun
the whole way through but really
allowing their backgrounds like you see
why she has such uh
animosity toward him you see why
he is so lonely why he acts the way he
does
um recently uh a person that watched it
was
uh talking about how chatty he is like
he's a chatty vampire
and then he as it goes on he starts to
realize like oh this guy is
like lonely like he's a monster and he
doesn't have anyone left in his life
like he's a lonely person who just
kind of wants to be loved
and so um you know even though he's a
monster and he's done terrible things to
people like he started just
you know so that sort of aspect i um and
that's really the scene where it really
comes out like he
and vanya does just such a great job
with
being both this just barbarian beast
but also being very vulnerable and very
uh
almost like this like childlike
innocence like he's this guy that just
never grew up
um never learned how to
take no for an answer or have to have
responsibility or anything like that
and uh yeah so i think he just
you know he delivers so well in that one
like there's a
there's one moment of it that still
every time his line delivery just brings
a little tear to my eye i'm just like
you just
like oh that's really sad and he just he
just sells it so well
so
how are you releasing blood from stone
it's a good question we're still sorting
it out because
everything's kind of been thrown topsy
turvy with the whole covid
lockdown stuff you know the initial plan
of doing like a limited little
theatrical release and then
going to vod kind of got torpedoed
and going straight to vod there's
nothing wrong with that and i'd be fine
with it
but trying to figure out something and
so
you know who knows fingers crossed i
hope this can happen
talking about doing driving theaters
seeing about that possibility so i would
love to
i think i think it's the right type of
film for that
frey would have been terrible for
drive-ins
that's just not the right atmosphere for
it i think this one could be a fun one
for that
so i'm hoping we can make that work but
um
if it doesn't and either way it'll you
know go straight it'll also
same time go to vod and streaming
services
but um it may you know depending on
you know what any rights finds out with
the whole market there
they've got one film to try it out with
first before mine
so depending on how that goes we'll see
if it's if it's worth doing um
you know people actually show up for
no-name indies at drive-ins then it'd be
great
um unfortunately we don't have a lot of
name cache in terms of uh
uh drawing in audiences so it's really
gonna depend on what audiences are up
for
and with the vod strategy i mean that's
where you're going to find most your
audience anyways with
a a no name indie and sometimes it takes
time i mean it took
fray not only did we reach those heights
it took
almost four years for it to peak at you
know
top 15 ward military films so
you know it's not like the old days
where you release it you have a big boom
of attention and then it kind of drifts
off
it's like you know it's a long game with
distribution with a no name indy it's
like
you know at first people might get a
little bit of attention from reviews
from all that type of stuff
but it's still gonna be uh you know it's
gonna take time to build up that
grassroots unless you got you know 100
to dump into marketing it's going to be
word of mouth people that see it
recommend it to somebody else
that person recommends it to somebody
else and then hopefully enough people
start watching it that the
you know algorithms of all these
different websites start clicking in and
start lifting it up in the rankings and
then you know you get enough reviews on
amazon you get enough reviews on imdb
and stuff like that people start taking
notice
and uh so it's kind of like we're doing
everything we can to try and like you
know build up enough of a release for it
that it'll have the attention to make at
least at least a little bit of a splash
you know um fray fray was a hard one it
was uh
when it first came out until the la
times review came out i couldn't pay
anyone to care about that movie
um even with our festival wins it was
hard to get anybody to really care
um you know we had some distributors
interested but in terms of media
interviews nobody cared um
it you know the la times review really
turned that around
but even then it was like that was too
that was the day it was released so it
was
too late to create a splash so it became
again about the long game
this one hopefully it'll be a little bit
of both hopefully once it releases be
able to get a lot of great reviews
or you know really hope they're it's
great reviews but you know we get a lot
of reviews get a lot of attention for it
and then
it can build up that word of mouth
because you know
thanks to streaming your film it's not
like the old video store days where you
know your film will be on the shelf for
a week and then the next week would be
in the bargain bin
um it's online as long as those
platforms last
so uh you know you got time to
make back your investment as long and
that was going back to like that quote
from michael madison from indie rights
where he
you know be able to do it for a price
where you can make your money back on
vod
is essential um you're not going to make
back a
2 million budget or a 5 million budget
through vod alone
but you can with you know with smaller
budgets
so how does the buzz from
blood from stone compare to fray i mean
already even though the film's not out
yet the buzz for blood from stone is
infinitely more than it was for frey um
frey it was wild because you know we got
grand jury prize dance with films got a
couple of the best film awards stuff
like that
and even with that it was so hard to get
anybody to care
about a no-name depressing drama
um about you know veterans issues it's
kind of like box office poison
um so you know we had distributors
interested the reason i liked going with
indie rights was because they were much
more
they seemed very honest and
straightforward about what to expect
from the movie
i didn't trust any distributor that said
it was going to do great
um but uh and they did they delivered on
it but it was so hard to get anybody to
care i mean even just getting a blogger
to interview us was a chore
um whereas this one i had a
teaser trailer cut about a year ago like
right after we wrapped shooting i had a
teaser trailer cut
and lyndon michael had it for one of the
film markets just wanted to show people
about this film that they have
in the works and uh you know it'll be
coming out in a year
and the thing literally got pirated from
a private server and leaked out to
youtube
it's like i could like literally nobody
watched my trailer for frey when i
released it little and pirated it
um so it was weird to think that and had
similar issues like the new trailer that
just released like as soon as we put it
out it was popping up every
on a bunch of other sites and so it's
just interesting to do a movie that
people are actually excited to see
um now again there's no big names but it
you know apparently from i mean
it's always hard when you're critics i
look at it and i just see a lot of stuff
i wish i could have done better or
that sort of thing but the reception i'm
getting from it from people have seen it
is that
you know it looks like a really exciting
very high production value
film uh just indifferent
you know people love the fact that it
looks different so it's
really crazy to see that that being said
there's still
you know there's gonna be a lot of work
put into amplifying that buzz and that's
that's the i would say my least favorite
part about the whole filmmaking process
is the marketing promotion side of it
it's like you know takes this thing that
for so long has been this pure art form
and now i'm turning into a commodity
and trying to sell it like okay what is
gonna sell this and all of it just feels
cheap and wrong um
so that's the part i'm trying to get my
brain wrapped around we can we don't
have much of a budget
so it's you know so much that's going to
be in the hands of myself
and the cast and crew to really
self-promote it as much as possible
um and so i'm grateful for the fact that
there's already been some interest and
people just seem to really like what
they see with it
uh and i guess
knowing you know if anyone that at least
looks into me knowing that you know
coming from the world of doing something
like fray
knowing that if i'm doing a vampire
movie it's not going to be
you know typical i think that's helping
too
what are your expectations from blood
from stone
the expectations that keep me awake at
night are the ones that i'm
optimistically hoping for
maybe both um yeah
i uh i don't know i tend to be
a very hopeful pessimist uh
i really hope that
that this film can speak
on a deeper level to people like i made
it intentionally it's very
i hope it's a really entertaining
feeling people enjoy and they walk out
of
being like that was a fun ride um you
know some of those films i mentioned
earlier
that i grew up loving all of them were a
fun ride it didn't matter how serious or
dark they got
they're also kind of a thrill to watch
like i wanted to do that but i also
you know we did a test screening of it
and
during the you know we had them
everybody fill out a form answering some
questions and afterwards just
you know ask them a few questions and a
few of them said like
i actually don't know what to say about
the movie yet there's a lot to process
and i like that i don't know you know
what they're going to come you know
what people are going to come back with
they might process it and go wow that
was a
you know lord a load of horse crap um or
maybe they'll process it and it'll
speak to him on a lot of levels uh
but i just hope that you know it's one
that does at least
make people think um make
you know reflect on their own past their
own actions how
you know how our actions can infect
others lives how you know
how somebody you know so much of the
politics and social stuff going on
thinking about the impact of the past
not just
my own personal past actions but
historical
past actions of an era that's putting me
in the position that i'm
in now that allows me to have advantages
that others don't have
and how that might breed resentment how
that might and try to
understand why people might not
you know might have some animosity might
have some some
feelings that aren't overly positive
even though i personally don't feel i've
done anything wrong
um those sorts of ideas or for somebody
that's
dealt with an abusive relationship for
them
to find that strength to
to escape from it and to know that going
out on your own
no matter who you are or where you're
coming from and going out on your own
means having that freedom to make
mistakes
so that's what i'm really hoping for is
i like films that make you think i like
films that afterwards you have a long
discussion about
i remember you know watching uh
the movie enter the void couldn't stand
that film
but was mind blown by at the same time i
was like
i mean friends i wouldn't see with we
had a four hour conversation after the
movie just about the movie
um and i still personally not a fan of
the film hated all the characters in it
but it was an amazing film that just
like i
have so much more respect for something
like that than something you walk out of
and you start thinking about like wait i
don't even remember what i just watched
so that's what i'm hoping to get out of
it um
and then on an aspirational side i would
love for it to do well
because honestly i want to do a sequel
for it
i really do i want i want to explore the
matriarchy of this vampire clan i want
i want to meet their mom i want to see
uh
victoria and her wife claudia i want to
see where
uh daria's life goes and i want i want
to be able to do that story so that's
the aspirational hope for it
is that uh it does well so i can keep
exploring that world
is that your next project or that's just
theoretically
in the future it'd be more expensive
than this one so this movie better do
really well otherwise that's not
happening
cause that one requires castles and i
also want to have flashbacks to when
uh when uh uray
first met daria and where her animosity
for him started why she has
a you know a grudge against him uh i
want to show her
life you know kind of where it was
dealing with that cyclical
nature of existence and you know
uh civilizations and all that i would
love the sequel to actually
explore that show literally have those
flashbacks of the past
and how those are so tied to the
the now and the present and be able to
show that full circle as opposed to just
talk about it so yeah i would love to go
that direction with it if i can
um if not i have another
micro budget script that i'm working on
that
deals with a lot of other similar themes
but is also a
passion project that i've had for a
while fermenting in the back of my head
if you were gonna teach your own
impromptu film class what five movies
would you require the students to watch
oh wow okay um
five movies i would have them watch the
first one i already mentioned it
uh samsara um
just the most pure perfect form of
filmmaking
uh that film i saw it four times in
theater made me cry every time at the
end
it is one of those powerful films i've
ever seen and there's not a word of
dialogue
or narration it's literally images music
and profound storytelling so that one
just as an experiment in like this is
the purest form of cinema there is
uh at least in my perspective um
the other one steve mcqueen's hunger
remember walking out of hunger being
both mind blown and depressed because i
realize i'll never make a film nearly
that good
but mcqueen's ability to make the most
visceral
exhausting brutal movie that
is composed of long takes and almost no
speaking
uh is just breathtaking again just pure
perfect
cinema so definitely those two
then it would be uh dr strangelove
uh for that one
is just how like the perfect political
satire the perfect film for you know you
take a director like kubrick is so known
for
heavy heavy films with very like nuanced
performances and just to go over the top
and
to be able to dissect them i could talk
about that one for a long time but just
how
that film has all the trademark
kubrick things but done in such a
different way
and to really understand comedy if you
don't know comedy your films are going
to be boring
i understand how comedy works i think is
so essential to filmmaking
uh you know i if i had one regret about
freights i didn't have enough
levity in it uh so definitely that one
um god what would it be uh
so that's three yeah i think um
oh uh
i would have to go like way back to um
did you ever see uh force of nature
uh i forget even the director's name but
i only found out about it because uh
scorsese said an interview is one of his
favorite films like well i gotta check
it out
it's a film noir um
it's such a it's a you know because it's
older it's a little bit simpler it's not
relying on like extreme production value
or whatever
pacing dialogue performance all the plot
points is one of the most efficient
enjoyable films i've ever seen so that
one just for like efficient smart
storytelling it's so good
and then oh god
um probably honestly like
a j.j abrams movie just because the guy
like if you want to make money
learn from the master this guy does pop
culture movies better than anybody
you know him or spielberg one of those
two where it's like you know take one of
their big hits and like
never forget to entertain your audience
either i think is like a key part of
filmmaking
is you know you can learn all the
artistry of the craft have all the heady
stuff in there
but don't forget people paid money or
gave you time of their life
and let them enjoy it too so
that'd be my my course that'd be your
course okay
and uh what would be the hardest
curriculum i mean sorry what would you
say what would be the hardest uh part of
the curriculum
what would be the one like sort of like
tough love uh
part of the class that uh maybe the
students would back at but you feel like
they would need to know
um i don't know i think like my
own regret actually i used to do i used
to do
talks at different film schools and i
always would tell people
the one thing that and you'll hate to
hear this because i didn't listen to it
when i was younger and the only way i
ever learned this
was tripping and falling flat on my face
a hundred times
running into walls trying to look for an
exit on a doorway to the next
step learn how to start up
a business if every film you do
is a business startup and if you don't
know how to properly start up a business
you are going to lose your ass for my
language
you're going to you're going to you know
it's unless you unless you're fortunate
enough to have
you know a proper investors and a
producer an executive producer and all
those people that are managing that for
you if you're doing like
bootstraps like making your own film
your way with whatever proceeds you
could
wrangle up you're making you're
starting up your own business approach
it as one no matter how low your budget
is
have a strat have a startup strategy
have a marketing strategy have all that
from
the moment that you're like oh this is
the script i'm gonna make
from that moment on start treating it
like a business as well because
if you don't you're gonna make a lot of
lot of dumb mistakes that i've made a
hundred times and learned the hard way
so i would honestly if i was truly
teaching a filmmaking course i would
have a whole
section on business startups and and you
know what do they say ninety percent of
startups fail
so let filmmakers know that you know
most films fail go into that knowing it
uh if you're not willing to accept
failure
then you'll never make something
original because you're going to be
constantly trying
to make something that's going to please
people which means it's going to be
based on what already exists
and if you're not willing to go out on a
limb
then you're not going to succeed so you
got to be willing to accept there's a
good chance i'm going to fail
you know i was saying it earlier fray i
expected nobody was going to watch it
um and i got lucky people did
um with this one i hope people want to
watch it but there's a part of me that's
really braced forward to just
tank i have no idea and i
would never want to go into a film
expecting it to be a success because
then you're just setting yourself up for
disappointment
so that would be that'd be my thing is
accept failure learn from it and know
that failure is what leads to
originality
and then learn business